this is jaco podcast number 109 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening echo good evening one September
1942 the Army in the field
comrade fighters commanders and
political workers heroic defenders of
Stalingrad the bitter fighting for the
city of Stalingrad has been raging for
months the Germans have lost hundreds of
tanks and planes
Hitler's brutalized hordes are advancing
toward Stalingrad and the Volga /
mountains of dead bodies of their own
men and officers our Bolshevik Party our
nation our great country have given us
the task not to let the enemy reach the
Volga to distr to defend the city of
Stalingrad the defense of Stalingrad is
of decisive importance for the whole
Soviet front without sparing our
strength and with scorn for death we
shall defy the Germans the way to the
Volga and not give up Stalingrad each
one of us must bear in mind that the
capture of Stalingrad by the Germans and
their advance to the Volga will give our
enemies new strength and weaken our own
forces not one step back the war council
expects unlimited courage tenacity and
heroism in the fight with the onrushing
enemy from all the fighters commanders
and political workers from all the
defenders of Stalingrad the enemy must
and will be smashed on the approaches to
Stalingrad forward against the enemy up
into the unremitting battle comrades for
Stalingrad for our great country death
to the German invader
so that is a clearly a note from the
general on the ground the member of the
war council of the Stalingrad and
Southwest Front lieutenant general
Khrushchev sent to the troops obviously
that we're preparing to defend
Stalingrad now there was another
commander in the field by the name of
Paulus and he sent a note to Hitler on
23 November 1942 my Fuhrer since receipt
of your radio message of evening 22 one
one vents have come thick and fast we
have not succeeded in closing the pocket
to the southwest and west
impending enemy penetrations begin to
emerge their ammunition and fuel are
coming to an end
numerous batteries and tanks have shot
themselves dry a timely and adequate
supply is impossible the army will
shortly be destroyed unless a
concentration of forces succeeds in
totally defeating the enemy attacking
from the south and west for this we must
immediately withdraw all forces from
Stalingrad and strong detachments from
the northern front an unavoidable sequel
must then be a break out towards the
southwest since eastern and northern
front can no longer be held with such
weak forces in this case we will even
lose much material but the majority of
the valuable combatants and at least a
part of the material will be preserved I
retain full responsibility for this
message even if I add that commanding
generals Heights Strecker Hubei Jacmel
von side let's all share this evaluation
of the situation based on the situation
I again request freedom of action Heil
my Fuhrer signed Paulus
the Russians were effective in
surrounding the Germans the German 6th
army as a matter of fact 250 to 300
thousand men fully surrounded now by the
Russians here's what Hitler wrote back
six army has been temporarily encircled
by Russian forces
I intend to concentrate the army in the
area Stalingrad north Koch Lube on Hill
137 Hill 135 marinovka
zebb n co stolid ground south the army
may rest assured that I will do
everything to bring supplies to it
accordingly and relieve it in time I
know the Braves 6th army and its
commander-in-chief and I am sure it will
do its duty signed Adolf Hitler so and
we'll get into this Hitler over and over
again is asked if the troops on the
ground can try and escape from
Stalingrad and over and over again he
says no you cannot leave you will fight
to the last bullet and on the 30th of
January 1943 Hermann Goering who is the
Nazi reichsmarschall of the entire
German Reich sir he's this senior
military man of the entire German army
from 1940 until the end of the war and
even though Stalingrad had not fallen
yet he gave this speech about their
sacrifice of these German soldiers and
he gave it being it was obviously heard
on the radio etc then it spread and
actually the soldiers on the ground in
Stalingrad the German soldiers heard
this speech and again we'll get more to
what the reactions were but I'm gonna
read that as part of that speech right
now it made one shudder but Stalin had
enormous masses at his disposal and
used old men women and children and did
not bother about supplies or sufficient
food or transport the Russians used the
whip or the bullet
the Germans alone could resist and could
wrestle with such an adversary
everything depended on them with the
greatest respect to other nations
the Germans are the only ones in Europe
in a position to break Russia and
destroy Bolshevism of all the terrific
battles the battle for Stalingrad stood
out like a gigantic monument which would
one day be regarded as the greatest and
most heroic battle in German history so
he's referring to this in the past tense
once again this is this hasn't been said
and finished yet but he's referring to
it like it's in the past tense because
for all practical purposes it was back
to the document every German soldier
would come to pronounce the word
Stalingrad with holy awe and remember
that it was there that germ Germany set
the seal of final victory because people
that fought like that
must win Germany has now become the
guarantor of European freedom culture
and life but for the fighters of
Stalingrad the Russians might have
obtained their objective now they are
too late the defenders of Stalingrad had
obeyed the law which everyone must obey
the law to die for Germany this law was
not only binding on soldiers but on the
whole German nation the nation must not
question whether its stand at Stalingrad
has been necessary or not the law had
ordered them to do so so here is saying
don't question no question the sacrifice
of two hundred and fifty thousand men
don't question it it was of no concern
to the German soldier whether he died at
Stalingrad in the African desert or
Norway he always sacrificed himself so
that his nation might live in ours when
some people perhaps tried to install
morbid and sly thoughts
to your brains then we must always look
at the Fuhrer there shining and greatest
example they could believe that the
almighty had led this man a god-sent man
to pass through innumerable dangers and
become greater and greater all for
nothing that Providence had given them
this man who had made them into the
strongest nation in the world
these are guarantees that justify our
belief in victory so we're talking about
Hitler here by the way as a god-sent man
in difficult times a real leader is
tested and people prove their worth in
hard trials I the commander in chief of
the Luftwaffe suffered exceptionally
when I heard of the results of the
bombings and although I did my best to
prevent it from happening it must be
recognized as unavoidable and must not
influence our will for resistance we
know a tremendous heroic song from a
match without equal that was called the
Battle of the Nibelungs they too stood
in a Hall of fire and fire quenching
their thirst with their own blood but
fought and fought to the last such a
fight is raging there today because of
people who can fight like that must win
and before these men a millennia
previous there stood in a small Gorge
and Greece and infinitely brave and
daring man with his 300 leonidas stood
with 300 Spartans from a tribe known for
its bravery and boldness and an
overwhelmingly numerical superior enemy
attacked and attacked and attacked again
and again even then it was a rush from
the Asian East against the Nordic people
huge numbers of men were available to
Xerxes
but the 300 men did not waver or falter
fighting a losing battle hopeless but
not meaningless and then the last man
fell and in this bottleneck there is a
sentence wanderer
if you come to Sparta report that you
had seen us lying here as the law
commanded they were 300 men my comrades
and millennia have passed but today that
battle that sacrifice still counts as
the greatest example of heroic
soldiering and today this fight is there
this sacrifice is there in Stalingrad
and one day it will be said if you go to
Germany
tell them you have seen us lying in
Stalingrad as the law commanded us to
protect the security of our people
and as I said those were the words of
Hermann Goering who was the senior
officer of the German military at that
time and those were his words and of
course his words were lies
all of them were lies and no one knew
that better than the men on the ground
in and around the Russian city of
Stalingrad nearly 1500 miles away from
Berlin freezing starving surrounded low
on ammunition lacking medical supplies
and lacking cold-weather gear and
lacking any kind of real leadership and
they also served in a nation that lacked
the moral high ground as a matter of
fact their nation's leaders lacked any
kind of morality at all and this is
clear and the aggression that they
unleashed in the world and the
atrocities that they committed mass
murder of millions of people and it's
clear that they had no morality
whatsoever based on how they treated
their own soldiers who like many
soldiers were men that were fighting not
for political powers or for political
ideals creating an ivory tower thousands
of miles away from them but for the
ideals of a soldier himself duty and
courage and honor that's what soldiers
fight for and the ultimate thing that
they fight for as we have heard time and
time again is for their brothers on the
line with them to their left and to
their right and one of those men
was named Johan wieder he was an
intelligence officer Tinley ate the core
of the German 6th army and he wrote
about his experiences in a book called
Stalingrad memories of Hell where he
recalls what he and other German
soldiers went through physically
mentally and spiritually as they were
abandoned by their leaders as they were
abandoned by life and as they were
abandoned by hope itself let's go to the
book again this is young Akeem wieder
and the book is called Stalingrad
memories of hell after meticulous
preparations of gigantic proportions the
Russians with their overwhelmingly
superior armor and cavalry forces
attacking like lightning from the north
and the following day from the east
pressed our entire sixth army into an
iron vise within three days the
encircling ring was closed at Kailash on
the Dan and kama dawn and constantly
reinforced stunned we stared at our
situation maps on which menacing thick
red lines of encirclement and arrows
showed the enemy attacks penetrations
and directions of advance we had never
imagined a catastrophe of such
proportions to be possible the mighty
wedges of the Russian armored columns
could not be stopped and a myriad of
highly mobile cavalry troops increased
the muddle and confusion in the rear of
the bloody rent front of the army
so you know obviously I skipped a little
bit moving into this poor point but at
this point they're completely surrounded
like I said cut off and the Russians are
applying the pressure the enemy appeared
to be systematically evading our blows
and to be withdrawing into the depths of
Russia so this is going he's kind of
reflecting back on how they ended up
there then he says that he says the
enemy appeared to be systematically
evading our blows and to be withdrawing
into the depths of Russia this is what
the Russians do that's what they did in
Napoleon in 1812 and they're doing it
again here and he back to the book taken
as a whole this was a masterpiece of
General Staff thinking today I am
convinced that those withdrawals of what
Russian forces during the summer of 1942
or an outstanding enactment of
traditional war Russian war tactics so
Hitler got lured in and they didn't pay
attention they didn't reflect on history
and as we all well as most people know
this was also Hitler opening another
front and trying to fight on multiple
fronts at the same time which which goes
against a certain law of combat called
prioritize and execute focus your forces
on your most important thing and then
move on Hitler gets an F on prioritize
and execute
back to the book it had now come to pass
we were actually caught in a trap how
were we to get out serious is the
situation in the pocket he refers to
this area as the pocket this is the
pocket of Russian soldiers serious as
the situation in the pocket was from the
very outset in our bunker there was
still an atmosphere of confidence and a
certain feeling of superiority so that's
by the way that's how you end up in
these situations and the Germans
absolutely believe their own propaganda
that they were the best soldiers and
that they were the master race and that
the these Bolsheviks couldn't fight them
hmm when you believe that you think you
can march right into Stalingrad and take
it mm-hmm no winders not gonna bother
you admittedly an eerie memory arose
within me and intensified my
apprehensive unrest with each passing
day it was the memory of several
fanatical statements that Hitler had
recently made in public speeches the
German soldier he said now stood on the
Volga and no power on earth could make
him leave the supreme warlord that's a
reference to Hitler the and he's got it
in quotes the supreme warlord had
emphatically committed himself he had
prophesized and demanded that Stalingrad
be relentlessly attacked and taken in
presumptuous terms he'd even sworn
before God and history never again to
relinquish on this conquest presenting
it as already achieved with such an
attitude as this on the part of the
supreme warlord was giving up the Volga
and retreating conceivable at all so
Hitler had painted himself into a corner
with a paintbrush of arrogance and it
ended up in this situation where he's
saying nope we're never gonna leave and
he does not back to the book the fate of
more than a quarter million human beings
was decided over such a distance so that
the Fuhrer headquarters is 2,000 mile
2,000 kilometers it's like 1500 miles
away and they're making decisions this
is called micromanagement mmm by the way
this is called micromanagement
this is not decentralized command this
is the fourth law of combat from the
book called extreme ownership Hitler
gets an F on decentralized command he's
micromanaging his troops that are 1500
miles away
the fate of more than a quarter million
human beings was decided over such a
distance from there Hitler repeatedly
addressed orders and appeals directly to
Stalin to the Stalingrad army which had
been removed from under the command of
Army Group B and reassigned to the newly
formed Army Group Don and then Don
DeLand is a river now everybody knew
that they needed to perform a military
maneuver referred to as a breakout which
means you picture you're in a circle
you're surrounded by troops you pick one
part of that circle of the people that
are surrounding you and you attack and
you break through it it sounds like what
it is it's a breakout everybody knew
that they needed to breakout they're
like hey we're surrounded we need fuel
we need water we need food we don't have
any of that we need to break out and so
everyone was kind of prepared to do that
back to the book our army still deposed
of about 130 combat ready tanks and
about the same number of armored scout
cars and other armored vehicles in other
words we still had a powerful motorized
units available everywhere people were
waiting for the relieving signal for the
breakout with fluttering hearts we
followed the preparations that were
taking place mainly in the western
sector of the army in anticipation of
the expected operation the order had be
given to destroy all superfluous
material everywhere damaged guns tanks
and trucks useless communication and
engineering equipment huge amounts of
clothing files and paper even food were
being consigned to flames so they all
think that they're gonna break out
they're assuming look we're gonna break
out this the only solution right now
we're surrounded we need to attack one
area and get out of here so they start
going okay before we leave we're gonna
burn this fuel we're gonna burn this
food we're not gonna leave anything for
the Russians back to the book according
to the decision by army command the
retreat from Stalingrad was
begin on 26 November we did not
entertain the slightest doubt that the
supreme command must be convinced of its
necessity we counted firmly on its being
carried out I will never forget how
stunned we all were
the agitation yes the petrifying horror
that befell us especially among the
higher ranks of our staff went on 24
November the message came in from Army
that Hitler had forbidden the planned
breakout and finally ordered the
Stalingrad army to temporarily take up a
position of all-around defense
so it was says no you're not leaving
oh you're surrounded by the way they're
surrounded by a force of about a million
Russian soldiers but but but it's more
than that because they're surrounded by
the country of Russia back to the book
the fatal radio message from the distant
führer headquarters had come like a
stroke of lightning forbidding the plan
withdraw of our northern front the
detachment of our forces from Stalingrad
and thereby the hope for the breakout
this decision by the supreme command was
just as heavy a blow for the staff at
the army as it was for us we were unable
to satisfy ourselves as to why all the
reports admonitions and requests for our
responsible of our responsible hire
staff who were best able to judge the
events and all the dangers they entailed
had not been successful so this is
something that Patton said the commander
on the ground is always right meaning if
you're sitting in an ivory tower
somewhere there's a guy on the ground
he's right and you're wrong he's on the
ground he knows what's happening
now could we come up with some
exceptions to this absolutely you have
better intelligence of what's happening
you maybe know some you maybe have
overhead coverage or you could you get
air reports or you have thin these days
you have satellites looking at things so
yeah there's situations where you might
know a little bit more but the default
thought process should be the guy on the
ground isn't is it has a better
situational awareness than I do I'm
gonna go with their call
and here's Hitler saying no
now general policies the commander of
all the all the German soldiers general
Paul's back to the book general Paulus
addressed himself directly to Hitler
with a very serious and responsible
evaluation of the situation in this
momentous radio message he had adamantly
stressed that the fact that all his
senior commanding generals shared the
conviction that because it would be
impossible to adequately supply the army
in time it would shortly be destroyed
unless a concentration of all available
forces were to succeed and divide
decisively beating the enemy attacking
from the West in the south so it's not
just one general at saying this every
but every user there's there's 250 and
300 thousand Germans there there's a lot
of senior military people all of them
are saying we need to leave mmm Hitler
says know why cuz Hitler is just that
like no you got you guys don't leave
because we're we're Germans we fight
till the death attained its arrogance
yeah I mean it's it's absolutely
partially arrogance that he thinks no
will hold out it will still just win to
where us yeah we'll just we'll just hold
it out and I think he's being stubborn
and yeah yes the kind where like he he
made a call kind of thing he made a
comment in there like hey with this the
calls no good we're gonna do this I made
the call yeah ego I mean obviously
Hitler hasn't I'm probably one of the
biggest egos of any human being ever and
he yeah in full effect even though he
had left no doubt but in his view the
decision promising salvation lane an
immediate break out in the end he too is
talking about Paulus in the end he too
submitted and obeyed for him an order
was an order in spite of everything all
that remained to us was to hope for a
rescue operation from the outside I will
say this actually you know there's some
books that parts of this book that I'm
not going to cover because we just don't
have time
well there's that guy that gave that
speech going in the beginning he had
also told Hitler hey don't worry we can
recently he was the before taking over
all the German military forces he was in
charge of the German air force the
Luftwaffe and he said look we can
resupply these guys don't worry about it
don't worry and he probably said that at
a time when it didn't look like they
were to get completely surrounded you
know oh yeah well we supply and don't
worry about and we'll get into some of
the numbers on what they said they could
do but that's another reason why Hitler
Hitler thought oh we can resupply he
also had people on the ground he's
surrounded by yes men yeah so no one
wants to disagree with the boss man in
this case Adolf Hitler by saying so when
he says look can't we resupply them yes
yes we can resupply them from the air
and also he was saying hey can't someone
instead of them breaking out and going
toward back towards Germany when we have
some German troops go towards them and
break in to them that way we can open up
some supply lines so what did he get
told when he when he offered that
solution he got told yes we can do it
yes we can do it
so he's surrounded by yes men and you
know how he ended up surrounded by yes
men he has he go hmm I don't like to be
told you're gonna tell me no you're
fired yeah get someone in here that's
gonna tell me that they can do what I'm
saying and then that person is gonna get
promoted and then you get surrounded by
people that want to get promoted
proceeding on and there was one general
that really made it made a significant
effort here we go back to the book
initially general Vaughn side blitz was
dumbfounded stunned he accepted the
order but in his heart he rejected it
particularly since he was painfully
aware that his own war hands were tied
not until the following day 25 November
1942 did General von Side 'let's react
to Hitler's orders and his reaction was
as much filled with a sense of
responsibility as it was temperamental
addressed to the army command it took
the form of a detailed evaluation of the
situation that the corps commander had
had his chief of staff prepare it
surmised once again all the arguments
against the Stalingrad army digging in
and urged the breaking out of the ring
immediately so what's cool about this
book they actually have this actual
document to the sky road if you ever
heard me talk on the podcast about
getting all your ducks in a row and like
hey if my boss tells me now cool I'm
gonna I'm gonna get all the information
I'm gonna come back and how many I'm
gonna make a bulletproof argument yeah
yeah my boss is going to agree with
because you can't my arguments gonna be
bulletproof because I'm right and if I
wasn't right then I wouldn't prison I
wouldn't go this far right I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna put my my reputation on
the line arguing something that I don't
truly believe is right you know I'll say
okay well you know what he could be
right so you know what I'm gonna try and
execute it to my best of my ability in
this case zeidlitz is like no it's not
no and and he says okay I'm gonna
perform I'm gonna put together this
thing they have the document inside this
book I would read it but it's long it's
it's so detailed that it would take too
much time but it lays out every little
detail of why they need to break out and
not an emotion that's what's beautiful
but not an emotional way how maybe I
just need to check myself because maybe
more emotion was needed but generally if
you come across as really emotional
Hitler would think all you well boss
would think oh you're just emotional
about the zecko use the emotional buddy
you just need to calm down
yeah it's carry out the orders so he
didn't he played the role or he used the
strategy of just calm this is what's
going on this is what needs to change or
this is what we need to do and if we
don't it's gonna be catastrophic
back to the book in the emergency
situation intensified by the okay agent
okay jazz Oberkommando de Ayer switches
the supreme high command of the German
army general von side let's demanded
from the commander in chief of the army
that he act immediately against orders
in other words against Hitler so so side
let's win silence got told no he's like
no listen we need to do it anyways
that's how passionate so now he's
starting to get a little bit emotional
and passionate he declared it to be an
imperative duty to the army and the
German people to obey the dictates of
conscious and to seize the freedom of
action that had been forbidden in order
to prevent threatening catastrophe the
memo was passed on by army come
and but had no effect whatsoever and so
they had to suffer the additional pain
that in the final analysis they could
but give in and fulfill the bitter
soldierly duty to obey against their own
better insight now I will tell you that
as Napoleon said if you execute a plan
that you know is wrong you are culpable
for executing it and these guys they
would not stand up against Hitler back
to the book we were all deeply disturbed
and full of despair and in our hearts
even outraged what was being demanded of
us not only contradicted all military
experience it went against every
soldierly feeling and robbed of us any
hope of any hope of being able to save
ourselves by breaking out under our own
power in the last week of November when
the formations that had been heavily
damaged during the initial retreat were
hastily and with great difficulty
establishing themselves on a new main
line of resistance army issued a grave
order of the day I can still remember
the exact warning it started sixth Army
has been surrounded this is not your
fault
as always you have fought bravely and
tenaciously up to the moment the enemy
had you by the neck it went on to point
out that the hard fighting suffering and
deprivation that would still be demanded
of the troops and which they would have
to endure for a time and hunger and
frost trusting in the help from outside
that had been so definitely promised so
Hitler did say I'm gonna send help from
the outside don't worry about it you
stay put finally mention was made of the
relief operation to which Hitler had
personally committed himself
psychologically clever and calculating
the appeal ended with the encouraging
words promising consolation and
salvation hauled on the Fuhrer will get
you out
this final sentence appealing so
strongly to emotion which injected a new
tone into the previously factual and
sober language of military orders gave
rise to discussions among our staff
it made me realize on top of all that it
already happened how great the sacrifice
was going to be that would be demanded
of the troops by the way these guys
traveled there and had a really hard
time of it they know how hard it was for
them to get there and now they're being
told that the people that are gonna the
way that they're gonna get saved is by
someone else coming behind them to help
them going through the same hardships
that they barely got there so they're
there their outlook isn't good it's a
job he had they're doubtful back to the
book a large number of the soldiers who
had been in constant exhaustion it is in
constant an exhausting action in the
frontline for two years without leave
without having been home to see their
loved ones so a lot of these guys so
they had actually survived a winter
early on they'd survived a winter as
they pushed into Germany as they put it
pushed in Russia and now they're waiting
for another one but these soldiers have
been fighting for two straight years
hard fighting back to the book naturally
the troops were not in a position to
appreciate the full extent of the
suffering and deprivation they were
about to face they knew nothing of the
difficult problems of the overall supply
situation so again this guy is working
at the headquarters meaning he's you
know with the commanders and the
leadership so he's tracking all the
logistics of the situation the frontline
soldier doesn't know the frontline
soldier expects hey they're gonna bring
me bullets they can bring me food he
realizes because he sees what's actually
happening that that's gonna be a real
problem
they had no inkling of the countless
worries that lay so heavily and
depressingly on the higher staffs nor at
first were they aware that that at one
stroke the encirclement had made it
impossible to complete preparations for
winter positions out there in the supply
depots of the army lay tens of thousands
of fur coats warm stockings protective
headgear and other items of winter
clothing which could now no longer reach
the encircled forces
for the most part the men remained
completely inadequately supplied with
winter gear and exposed to the murderous
Frost so they had thousands and
thousands of warm weather gear or I
should say cold weather gear and now
they're gonna get nothing they're cut
off back to the book we calculated that
our own army whose total strength before
the encirclement had been about three
hundred and thirty thousand men now
numbered about two hundred and eighty
thousand so they're already short fifty
thousand killed we the staff the
officers in the staff departments also
pinned our hopes on the relief operation
which was being prepared
no one even considered that Hitler would
be ready to abandon the outstandingly
proven sixth army on the Volga and throw
it to the walls so these guys are even
though I said that even though I said
they weren't hopeful they're also
thinking there's no way that Hitler is
gonna leave three hundred thousand
soldiers out here there's no way back to
the book he was bound to find ways and
means to rectify the devilish situation
there were even starry-eyed dreamers not
however among the older and more
experienced who maintained that the
Fuhrer would not only get us out but it
probably already conceived a plan to
turn our apparent defeat into a glorious
triumph by encircling all the enemy's
armies that are surrounding us
none of these dreamers and believers in
miracles who kept those who kept
surfacing here and there until the very
end had a clear idea of what was implied
by the fact that German soldiers were
simultaneously fighting on the North
Cape and the Bay of Biscay in the front
of Leningrad and veers ve' on in the
caucus in Crete and in North Africa so
again this guy's fighting fronts all
over the place and and the staff
officers the leadership knew how thinly
spread the German army was the frontline
troops didn't you know they didn't make
sense of that during the weeks of
December the fighting strength of the
army was deteriorating at a horrendous
pace the blame for this lay mainly in
the in the inadequate airlift here a
catastrophic picture was slowly emerging
in order to be able to maintain its
ability to live and fight our army had
initially requested 750 tons of supplies
per day later reducing this to 500 tons
per day the Ju 52 cargo aircraft had
about a 2 ton load the want the 80111
fighter bomber had held about 1.5 tons
so this is gonna require like 2,000
aircraft to be able to make this happen
what do they end up with back to the
book they only brought in 80 to 120 tons
of the required supplies in other words
not more than one-fifth of the amount
needed purely and simply this meant a
daily deficit of ten thousand kilograms
of bread and a fatal under supply of
desperately needed fuel and ammunition
we're getting 1/5 of what they need now
we have to be careful because that's a
little statistic that we're throwing out
there right like oh we're getting 1/5 of
what we need but I'll think of a human
being in what you need is a human being
just food can you cut that down to 1/5
of what you need
you know you need 2,500 calories a day
you're gonna get 500 mmm that's what
we're talking about yeah you need and
and by the way you're fighting and
you're gonna you're being attacked so
you need thousand bullets a day right
you need a thousand bullets a day you're
getting a hundred and twenty bullets
it's it's there
things are not looking good back to the
book the sunset soon after lunch and by
1400 to 1500 hours it was already dark
so this is now we're talking rush in
winter by 2 or 3 o'clock in the
afternoon it's dark and every day this
too reminded us to depressingly here in
the desolation of the snow bream it's no
bounce step of the enormous distance
that separated us from home
were we not all the living and the dead
long buried in a gigantic mass grave
thoughts like this occasionally befell
me when I returned from various sectors
of the front where in my role as liaison
officer I had been sent on specific
assignments to gather urgently needed
information there on the heights above
the infamous row Chaka Valley the men of
our divisions lay in desperate battle
demanding bloody sacrifice there in the
trenches and foxholes and the snow the
soldiers were dying of exhaustion and
cold because their steadily shrinking
rations of bread and other food issued
food issued were no longer sufficient to
provide the physical stamina needed to
combat frost and sickness so they're
starving to death they're starving to
death in the freezing to death and
they're being attacked and killed by the
Russians with no ammo with no ammo one
day in the second week of December the
staffs first heard the news that the
army group Dawn under Field Marshal van
main Stein von Manstein had begun the
long hope relief for the long hope for
relief operation soon the good news had
also reached the Troops the words gave
new impetus everywhere and particularly
on the hard-pressed western perimeter of
the pocket spread like lightning
mainstay man Stein is coming.the already
dying hopes burst forth anew new courage
happy expectations a new spirit of
initiative began to blossom the
sufferings and sacrifices to date had
not been in vain after all salvation was
now beckoning what the Fuhrer had
promised he was bound to deliver so they
get work Ben Stein's coming this is this
is good if everything went well they
thought the hour of all relief could
just coincide with Christmas the
motorized groups and strong tank units
being led by Colonel general Hoff
elements of which had been brought in
from France and great haste had begun
there
relief offensive Hoth spearhead tanks
were only 50 kilometers away hold on
we're coming said one of the encouraging
radio messages which spread like
wildfire amongst the western edge of the
pocket so they're in radio communication
50 kilometers and this well-respected
leader Hoff he's on the way any time
hold on we're coming
do you ever that isn't that like a jinx
right there
you know what I mean like do you ever
celebrate something inside your head you
celebrate something a little bit before
you should yeah don't ever do that
am i superstitious because I believe
that way if you think that that's how it
truly works but I think um I think it's
superstitious but I also think there's
some psychology because yeah yeah I
think yeah yeah where especially if you
realize see if you just realized oh I
just celebrated earlier right there it's
kind of makes you uneasy or something
like that I feel like that guy that guy
got a certain level of satisfaction just
by saying like don't worry we're coming
like he had this moment of glory that's
glorious that's a glorious leader to be
able to say yeah don't worry we're
coming yeah yeah it's a glorious thing
to be able to say and he took that he
took the easy money right there
psychologically instead of being like
hey we're not there yet we need to be
ready I hardly know fast worry about
where we are yeah yeah finish strong
right yeah and the thing it's like the
guy who's running the touchdown right he
celebrates the 30-yard line
right the 25 he puts the hand up there's
like a classic shot and the guy creeps
up behind the point you know what this
guy was named Leon led he played for
the-- I want to say Dallas Cowboys he
was like a like a deep around wave year
I want to say 90s me how many other
Dallas Cowboy players can you remember
the name up from the 90s um do you
remember a lot of them like a handful
just let the quarterly on one brahim
he's infamous that's life for this poor
guy you know he he's a defensive like
lying man or something recovers a fumble
runs it in for the touchdown and he's
he's doing
he's not even due putting in the above
his head he's putting it on the side
kinda like celebrating its homeland I
think they stripped them and recovered
it I think if I'm not mistaken yeah
psychologically you can't stop strong
see money you gotta finish this great to
the finish line or that like races like
100-meter dash you know the guys like or
the 200 meter he's like yeah I wanted
the real hungry guy gets it you know it
did so--that's whof whof takes the easy
money dan can be doing it huh back to
the book in the sure knowledge that
before us was the last chance for our
salvation we fiercely awaited the
decisive hour with a feeling of
confidence the orders we expected could
not be delayed much longer but all too
soon our hopes were to be bitterly
disappointed alarming messages began to
came in rapidly attacking Russian tank
forces were embroiling the relieving
army and heavy fighting were slowing the
advance and finally leading in
connection with the Russian offensive
group operations west of the dawn to a
serious crisis for the entire Army Group
one of the attacks hit Colonel general
Hoff who is hastening towards us in
fearful tension and delay mounting an
agitation we read the messages we were
receiving from the far distant German
air reconnaissance and radio
surveillance units soon these brought
news of disaster the relief operation
had began to run down Haas forces in
turn threatened with being surrounded
were finally forced to retreat the front
fell back hundreds of kilometers and the
encircled Stalingrad Army on the Volga
was left to its fate only much later was
I to learn of tragic details of the
events and circumstances that had sealed
the fate of the encircled army at this
point I did not know then that Hitler
was still in no way prepared to give up
Stalingrad on the Volga that for the
second time and after the dramatic
conflicts and the conflicts that he's
talking about is between him between
Hitler and the people the his advisors
he had explicitly forbidden the breakout
of the 6th army against the will of his
chief of
staff and in opposition to the demands
of the army group Don so Hitler leaves
them abandons them back to the book
among the circle of our closer comrades
we no longer entertained any illusions
about the bleakness of our situation the
German front had withdrawn a great
distance away and for the time being
there would be no new thought unearthed
no thought of a new relief operation
would the German front be able to hold
out for several more weeks
it was hardly to be expected hunger
frost and sickness were cutting terribly
into its waning strength and death was
reaping an uncanny harvest and not only
on the fire spewing iron ring around the
pocket and even the conditions for a
great saving breakout operation scarcely
existed any longer in such an event the
army would only be able to remain of
mobile for a few kilometers because the
lack of fuel and if Stalingrad wilted
were to be given up what then would
happen to the growing army of wounded
sick and exhausted men did the okh
intend to give up the Volga at all the
measures ordered so far seemed to point
the opposite way once again I was often
forced to recall Hitler's fanatical war
words about the German soldier on the
Volga about Stalingrad and each time an
icy unease crept through my bones maybe
yes maybe we were supposed to hold on to
the bitter end to stay put and fight to
the last bullet on the dark horizon the
outlines of a terrible disaster began to
emerge
Christmas Eve approached all the visible
and invisible wounds which the cruel
events had caused burned even more
painfully on this night the atmosphere
was depressed memories of former
Christmas celebrations with their
blissful shimmer
me dimly illuminated our harsh reality
as from a world long gone
the well-loved Christmas carol sounded
in low melancholy sadness so hope is
pretty much vanquished at this point not
completely because he still in May he's
still saying maybe maybe they're just
gonna leave us here and fight to the
last man which is a crazy thought
because I'm gonna say this number again
two hundred and fifty to three hundred
thousand soldiers
this isn't like hey you've got 18 guys
fight to last man it's the Alamo right
this isn't that this because that that
might have you know that that's not
gonna have a strategic impact on the
situation
you lose 300,000 combat veterans which
which you know the hard combat hardened
veterans this is gonna have a strategic
implication I mean of course every
soldier that dies is is a epic event in
that soldier's life obviously in their
family and everything else but when you
start talking about leaving 300,000
people to die for nothing
it's it's he still can't quite get that
he's still not quite there he sees it on
the horizon he's not quite there though
back to the book the New Year had
arrived jangling Frost layover
Stalingrad over the Stalingrad pocket
and breathed its icy deadly breath the
sharp wind blew through the joints of
doors and windows and in the bunkers and
from the floors the cold crept up to
one's knees the daily casualty reports
from our divisions that increasingly
reported losses other than by enemy
action represented a shattering balance
on the death sheet so what are you
saying there is like yeah people are
dying from combat but even more people
are dying just from cold and starvation
yeah again the Russians furiously
attacked several sectors of our
perimeter what did we have left to
oppose these powerful Russian elite
troops who were
protected from the frost and had a full
stomach not to mention their numerous
tanks guns rocket launchers and mortars
only small numbers of heavy weapons with
insufficient strictly rationed and
munition it's all we had only emaciated
men exhausted by hunger among whom the
fighting the cold and spreading diseases
were taking of daily frightening toll
how much longer could the perimeter
withstand the pressure it did not escape
our attention that the Russians appear
to be concentrating in front of our
sector in preparation for a major blow
the last saw sad possibility grew even
clearer on the dark horizon the fate of
our destruction by a shattering
offensive breaking over our heads so
again it's interesting that this guy's
well two things I should point out
number one it's interesting that this
guy's perspective because he's in the
staff and so he sees more of what's
happening from the general officers but
let's also make note that he's not on
the frontlines and he's so he has it
relatively good meaning he's protected
by the by the rush from the Russians by
some distance I mean he's still getting
mortared etc still getting artillery but
he's not he's not I to I with the
Russians like the guys like the soldiers
on the front lines that are sitting in a
little slit trench in the ground and the
tundra well one of the things that he
sees is a meeting here we go back to the
book an important meeting of the general
staff took place at our core which the
commander in chief of the Army General
Paulus attended with his chief of staff
the serious reserved expression of the
tall figure with the head of a scientist
reflected something of a burden of
responsibility that pressed down
tormenting Lee on the shoulders of this
man it was the last time I was to see
her army commander in the pocket as far
as I can remember he never visited our
core again I soon learned of the outcome
of the meeting and the grave words of
our General Staff officers left no doubt
about the consequences of the orders
that had been issued in the meantime
they dealt with the mobilization of the
last reserves of the 6th army the
encircled forces would hold on and fight
to the last for this purpose the
formation of fortress battalions was to
be prepared and executed as quickly as
possible all remaining reserves of
able-bodied men were to be collected and
uses infantry members of the Luftwaffe
ground personnel and anti-aircraft
troops Gunners who no longer had guns
Panzer grenadiers x' engineers truck
drivers clerical staff SRIA chillon and
supply personnel or once again to be
ruthlessly combed out the order amounted
to the virtual dissolution of the rear
echelon services and clearly
demonstrated that the immobilized army
was doomed to stay put and fight to the
last man and the last bullet so there
you go everyone's gonna fight cooks
supply people you're all gonna be coming
in for treatment now and this clearly
indicates to wieder that that means
they're not going anywhere and they're
gonna stay there they're gonna fight to
the last man back to the book we felt
that we had already been written off by
the higher-ups and all that remained for
us was to perform a heroic if futile
gesture to ensure the fulfillment of a
historic mission and he's got quotes
around that of the army of Stalingrad on
the Volga the troops were again given
the cheering radio message which the
Fuhrer and supreme warlord had sent at
the turn of the year six army has my
promise that everything is being done to
get it out but we now viewed this not
just with doubt but as downright
deception they don't believe Hitler
anymore they used to just doubt him now
now they think he's deceiving him and
again this is not there's no small group
people yeah back to the book the bread
ration was reduced to 50 grams per day
wringing cold gnawing hunger creeping
illness enemy fire combined in an
indispensable
dysentery and typhoid fever had appeared
as uncanny guests and the plague of lice
increased from day to day
death danced his murderous Rondo back
and forth throughout the pocket his
headquarters were the numerous places of
suffering despair the dressing stations
and field hospitals that filled to
overflowing alarmingly but he also felt
at home on the lines day and night so
death is everywhere it isn't it weird
you know you think like just being sick
you were telling me you were sick a
couple days ago common cold but yeah
yeah and you think about what being sick
does to you and now this is your being
second it doesn't matter like there's no
mercy yeah there's no mercy back to the
back during back the book during 50 days
that pocket battle lasted so far he and
he's talking about death he had already
cleaned out horribly among the men of
the army about one-third of its manpower
was gone of the more than 300,000 men
who were present at the time of the
Russian breakthrough about 200,000 were
probably still alive and how many of
these enduring and hoping fighting and
suffering human beings had death not
already marked on his own news that we
could no longer count on any relief
before spring was really shattering
there was nothing more to be done saved
to hang on and endure the horror now we
get a little opportunity here here we go
there was a surrender proposal sent to
our encircled army by the soviet supreme
command the document was addressed to
Paulus who had been promoted to Colonel
general and to all the officers and Men
of the German forces fighting at
Stalingrad it was signed by Colonel
general of the artillery for Verona and
by the commander-in-chief of forces of
the dawn front lieutenant general roca
Sowinski who had now obviously been put
in
sole charge of all the forces
surrounding us the proposal began with a
short factual and largely correct
evaluation of our situation in
particular it stressed the catastrophic
state of supply of our troops who are
suffering from hunger cold and sickness
lack of winter clothing and terribly
insanitary conditions realistic
possibilities of breaking the encircling
ring no longer existed any further
resistance in such a hopeless situation
had to be senseless therefore in order
to avoid further unnecessary shedding of
blood the Red Army was proposing a
number of terms the document ended with
a reference directed to the
commander-in-chief of stalingrad army
pointing out that in the event of
refusal the forces of the Red Army and
Air Force would be obliged to destroy
the pocket for which he colonel general
Paulus would bear the responsibility
they still got 200,000 people and you
get an offer you get 24 hours to respond
basically surrender everybody yeah
everybody's gonna surrender yeah and and
they weren't sure how they were gonna
get treated mmm I mean they were fairly
confident wasn't be treated good all the
dysentery nobody did very good either
that's not treating you very good at all
back to the book we soon received
various orders directives and messages
whose burden was that the surrender was
out of the question the commander in
chief had passed the Russian ultimatum
on to the führer headquarters and asked
for freedom of action for all
eventualities an immediate reply Hitler
it personally forbidden surrender and
Paulus had rejected in writing the
proposal the Soviet command the troops
were not informed not to be informed in
detail but from now on they were ordered
to fire without warning on flags of
truth of truce appearing near the front
lines this instruction from Army which
we received by radio was especially
feeling as to the intentions of
leadership in our staff it was received
with a rejection and objection because
it was a clear breach of international
law so they don't get told like hey
we're not surrendering what they get
told is if you see anyone with flags of
truce shoot him immediately which is
basically saying we're not surrendering
back to the book I was reminded again of
Hitler's high-sounding words about the
invincibility of the German soldier for
whom nothing must be seen to be
impossible the very thought of
capitulation must be an irreconcilable
must be irreconcilable with the prestige
of the supreme warlord he puts that in
quotes every time I I don't call it out
every time but he does he's sort of
mocking Hitler when that in his speech
in Munich shortly before our
encirclement he had had he not solemnly
sworn you may rest assured I repeat this
with full responsibility before God in
history that we shall never again leave
Stalingrad never again for life or death
we were committed to the cheerless dawn
step here our fate must come filter the
most terrible weeks were still before us
and during those icy days in January the
fearful premonition of what was to come
descended upon us like a lead weight on
the morning of 10 January 1943 exactly
24 hours after the ultimatum had expired
the Russian began the destruction of the
pocket with a hellish artillery barrage
it was the answer to the rejection of
the surrender proposal up up front among
the staffs on the line I again entered
the atmosphere of tension excitement
nervousness and despair the situation
was partially unclear and confused the
cat the catastrophe did indeed appear to
be unavoidable into this helpless
situation orders from Army came in time
and time again defend hold clear up the
situation fight to the last bullet from
their desks 2,000 kilometers away and he
puts in parentheses an exclamation point
the okh
together with the constantly interfering
fear her führer headquarters forbade any
independent withdrawal from endangered
from endangered sectors of the perimeter
an army which had to meticulously
justify itself for any change in the
front line caused by the pressure of
circumstances obeyed so this classic its
micromanagement not decentralized
command they're even saying look if
you're if you're if your perimeters
gonna collapse don't fall back just die
which is ridiculous because it doesn't
help the situation because now there's a
hole and now more more enemy are gonna
come through the hole and we're gonna
have people behind us yeah it's like
full-on kind of what you were talking
about last week maybe last week it's
like do it cuz I said so kind of thing
like there's no really is gonna die
there's no reason to do it no strategic
reason no tactical reason obviously
let's do it cuz I said so yeah whatever
yeah the Army Corps divisions and
regiments obeyed often with bitter
Chris's criticism with open or hidden
reservations flaring up or knuckling
under but they obeyed and the suffering
and dying of troops in the trenches and
foxholes in the icy steppe obeyed giving
their all in the natural fulfillment of
their duty or an apathy and silent
despair the higher leadership did not
stint with recognition
promotions decorations and medals rain
down on mass on the fighting suffering
doomed men but what purpose did this
huge monstrous commitment and dedication
of human being serve in the face of the
increasingly help military helplessness
and the daily worsening human plight I
was becoming more and more depressed by
the torturing question of the why of
this sacrifice of most precious blood
this pitiless dining was it not only for
the sake of a prestige that a military
supreme command thousands of kilometers
removed
mercilessly wished to maintain than for
whom the price and many thousands of
human lives did not appear to be too
high this question haunted me and would
not leave me until the final sorrowful
ending so he's asking why they start to
collapse from the perimeter of the
pocket in towards the city of Stalingrad
because they were kind of pushed out
around it surrounding it and now they're
starting to fall back to it where they
at least have some coverage back to the
book the withdrawal of the troops
finally turned into a full-fledged
flight into which further formations and
combat groups of various divisions were
drawn whole units cease to exist in this
confusion in the sector of our neighbor
to our left this fate also put an end to
a whole division that had long been
under our command and in the end had
burned out like a slag heap I saw it's
distraught general now a commander
without troops wandering around in a
bunker desperately seeking a new
assignment so he just lost 20,000 men
he's walking around saying what am I
supposed to do now back to the book and
this desperate withdrawal was being
carried out in icy cold weather and
pitiless snowstorms at 30 degrees
centigrade below zero that's negative 22
at 30 degrees below zero the remnant of
the regiments that had shrunk to combat
groups and the suffering hordes of their
shed of other shattered units moved over
the empty white steppe staggering crowds
dragging dragging crowds of lost lightly
wounded and frostbitten soldiers with
them how many of those that so far had
been spared
enemy fire succumbed there to exhaustion
and over exertion to the strains of
hunger and
to the cold innumerable men fell by the
wayside and were soon mercifully covered
over by the snow and this was no longer
an authorized withdrawal the recoil of
the front was now taking place despite
standing orders to hold and maintain
position at all costs and despite the
line of resistance laid down by the okh
so they finally did break they finally
said you know what survival this is
about survival and we're not staying
here anymore I'm gonna try and get back
fall back the cycle the psychological
ability of the troops to resist had now
also been eroded there could no longer
be any doubt about our fate after the
enemy had begun his decisive attack bent
on destruction and our dissolution was
in full progress it was too late for a
last departure attempt to break out to
the west help from outside could no
longer be considered more devastating
even than the enemy's weapons were
hunger exhaustion cold an illness of all
kinds among the soldiers who had not
been adequately fed for so many long
weeks with the advent of the in credit
indescribable strains of daily retreats
the situation had deteriorated
catastrophic ly we were lacking in food
weapons rest warmth hope in short we
were lacking in all the vital conditions
for fighting since the long rejection of
the surrender proposal the troops had
again survived a long terrible week of
tenacious defensive fighting retreat and
flight thereby tying down superior and
enemy forces in their area now after the
loss of our life support base Potomac
airfield On January 16th the time really
seemed to have come to stop fighting the
airlift temporarily ceased altogether
no more food and ammunition came in the
wounded and sick could no longer be
flown out and so that's where they're
getting their supplies into Potomac
airfield and that's actually where this
guy
was for a large chunk of this battle
it's now gone so now they even you know
before they were they were only getting
one-fifth of what they needed well now
they're getting zero by now every day
that the fighting was prolonged was
costing thousands of human lives there
was no more time to be lost
and we waited for something to happen
like me innumerable comrades and
brothers and fate probably clung to the
same secret hope but nothing happened
and tragedy took its course the Russians
by using their storm troops during the
initial days of the offensive it would
probably have been very easy for them to
make a further effort and liquidate the
pocket relatively quickly but they no
longer needed to make such a highly
costly attempt time was on their side by
bearing down on our tenacious defense
with a crushing attack our enemy had won
its penetration into the pocket now he
was no longer in a hurry and no longer
appeared to consider his victim to be
very dangerous the battle that had begun
in the meantime was merely a question of
finishing off wounded game already
marked for death for some time already
the Russians had dictated the course of
events the date of our final end
depended on their will alone the
Stations of the Cross of an army of
200,000 soldiers particularly because of
the slow helpless death of such a vast
number of human beings made anything
seen before with the exception of Verdun
pale by comparison a part of the entire
German nation was sentenced to death
here and by this it's vital substance
was dangerously under attack the moral
effect of these events touched the whole
nation in the midst of the general
destruction of the army there were
thousands of individual tragedies whose
localities of horror were the numerous
collection points for the sick and
wounded whole convoys of mostly open
trucks overloaded
they're pitiable Freight of freezing
wounded groaning sick and dying move
deeper into the pocket from the second
half of January until the bitter end the
harsh suffering of the fighting soldiers
continued by day and night after eight
evil weeks of indescribable torture and
deprivation they were now plunged into a
veritable hell of hopelessness and
destruction time and again it was fight
resist hold to the end then disengage
withdraw turn back and digging again for
defense and the snow and stonily hard
frozen earth time and again there were
heavy losses panic and flight and the
neverending useless struggler struggle
against hunger and cold among the staffs
there was an unending tension perplexity
and despair and feverish activity
leadership was still to be seen from the
higher hat commands came continual
orders directives questions admonitions
threats criticism opposition and
misgivings were not lacking at the lower
levels but for the time being the
mechanisms of command still function so
despite all this and even though they're
having this this hasty withdrawal that's
going against orders there's still our
direction coming out there's still
people being disciplined in the midst of
the general suffering and dying we
helplessly watch the catastrophe and of
destruction approaching us mercilessly
and inexorably the terrible human
tragedy that was nearing its climax was
finally commented commented upon by the
war news broadcast at home in the pretty
and spirited words it quote in
Stalingrad 6th army is attaching
immortal honor to its banners by its
heroic and self-sacrificing battle
against crushing odds
many of my comrades had mentally written
themselves off intentions to commit
suicide were voiced with increasing
frequency others had given their
valuables and wedding rings to be to the
wounded being flown out I myself had
been had so far been at pains to prepare
my relatives for the catastrophe by
means of sparse hints now I felt the
need to send home open word of farewell
and gratitude the letter was hard to
write in my ears once more rang rang the
last goodbye my wife had imploringly and
beseechingly called down the telephone
line to Kiev on a spring evening of last
year before the seemingly endless space
of Russian planes had swallowed me up
now all would soon be over when I sealed
the letter I was gripped by especially
deep despair I felt as though I were
suddenly looking into an abyss of
suffering and hopelessness towards which
our whole nation was reeling as if the
events in Stalingrad were a preview of
an immeasurable disaster that was to
break upon Germany the general of this
division division had a nervous
breakdown it was no longer fit for
command his hopes of being flown out
what the badly wounded and sick had not
been for full fulfilled he now had to
share the fate of his soldiers to the
bitter end this general who a short time
before was a commander of a division had
carried the responsibility for many
thousands of men was once more a mere
human being trembling for his life then
did his questions not reveal the same
fear that secretly tormented all of us
we made one another realize that the
impending military catastrophe was also
a political catastrophe the result of
presumptuous beliefs and actions that
had long shaken the healthy foundations
of our intellectual cultural and
national life had the power that we
served as citizens and soldiers bent its
knee before the law that was rooted in
the code of ethics or rather had not a
new gospel of violence been proclaimed
and introduced that in a fatal reversal
of all values had ceased to
differentiate between right and wrong so
these guys are realizing what's coming
around what's coming around he's
realizing that the path that they went
down as a country was wrong back to the
book by means of destructive battle
against the universal educational and
cultural powers of classic antiquity
humanism and Christianity and anti
intellectual political religion of power
had successively extracted the German
people from the best of the commonly
held european body of human thought and
thereby also out of any commitment to
the objective concepts of truth
compassion and justice is that is that
his conclusion like during this events
or yes during these events he's
realizing what what's happening yeah is
that they were wrong and they went I
mean the thing that's crazy about Nazi
Germany is how fast that transition took
place like took in ten years what the
rise of the not to rise the Nazis are
there and their their influence in that
yeah the rise of the Nazi straight up
1933 they started now 1943 so or ten
years and you have a completely
different viewpoint of the world yeah I
mean starts they're going against they
see what like they're going against the
traditional values they're going against
hey you know they're going against the
Christian values they're going against
the cultural values they're going
against the national values they're
going against them yeah
and it's I wonder how much of it is you
know like the soldiers and that even the
people in the Nazi Party I wonder how
much of it is like denial you know you
know where it's a you know how like
you're signed on to like some leading
during the during the time being yeah
are you saying right now how much does
this denial no no during terms you know
what I remember Rape of Nanking you
remember that there is one of the nicest
guys one of the guys who made the
biggest sacrifice was this was a
straight-up actual Nazi and he made
massive sacrifice and took huge risk to
save as many people as he could by the
way not white people not Aryans but but
Chinese yeah so so there's a guy that
you know was more related to the
traditional Christian intellectual
values right and yet okay the the people
that in charge of the country is Nazi so
I guess that makes me a Nazi yeah and
here we go and so and these guys worse
situation because they're soldiers so
now they're fighting for that evil force
and like you said there's some denial
you also get caught up and clearly the
Germans got caught up in the nationalism
they got caught up a Hitler was a great
orator and a very moving speaker and
they got caught up in that and they were
in a very depressed economy so those
things all kind of came to that they'd
been in their mind screwed over in World
War one and you know defeated and then
treated badly and you know there's this
whole thing about Hitler's mustache
you know Hitler's got the funny mustache
sure and there's some debate on on how
much of this is actually true but
whether it's true or not is a little bit
it doesn't really matter but because of
what it represents so that the deal was
that Hitler's mustache if you wanted to
have a mustache during World War one
because of wearing a gas mask you had to
cut your mustache like that Hitler still
wore his mustache like that it was like
a constant symbol that he remembered mmm
he remember cuz he was in World War one
and he was wounded in World War one and
through the even despite all that insane
sacrifice they didn't win and they
didn't like the way they got treated by
the Treaty of Versailles and so they had
that angst they had the economic Hank's
they had all those angst built up and
Hitler came along
is ready to let them focus on something
else and and now what what we der is
realizing here is like yeah he had us
focus on something else all right
and what he had his focus on wasn't good
it was evil this is a crude analogy you
are training day
I have watched training day that's kind
of the same thing when you watch cuz
Jean what way cuz the new use the
trainee by the way when I see a movie I
see it like one time in an airplane and
I'm not I'm not gonna be fully familiar
with so hearing the rise of Nazi
journalist and millions of people to the
movie training yeah well in this total
the speculation is just what we're
talking about as far as like you know
people they're signed on hey I'm German
you know that's cool and you know we're
all German weren't you know solidarity
word your and then kind of the Nazi
Party starts rising starts giving these
sort of it sort of certain types of
influence and they're like oh alright
cool I mean I wasn't really thinking
that but all right we're still Germans
we're cool and it starts escalating and
slowly it's like okay so you can't you
can't turn back it doesn't happen a
training day right yeah like he's signed
on little sign nothing and he's like
dang he's like I don't know about all
this but all right hey I'm signed on to
the cause and after a while which is the
same point that this guy got got to
where it's like man okay you guys pushed
it too much man I can't sign onto this
and then you reflect back on all the
violations you know like and you start
to slip you start to slip when you don't
hold the line yes yeah that's what
happens yeah and that's what makes
leadership hard that's what makes life
hard yeah it's really easy to get
tempted to go down these trails these
paths that are not what you should be
doing right okay you gotta kind of in
MIT MIT and it's hard because in the in
the beginning like you know you're going
down the path you're already signed on
right and you see one teeny tiny
violation and it's like what am I going
to do like make this big stink about
this teeny-tiny violation yeah
all right then you keep going and then
you had already made that exception
time goes on is what do you do bring
together psychologically
but Denzel Washington he's he's in his
introduced he's not go straight to level
eight violation right he just he just
gives little yeah little violations tip
anything down the pay a little bit abuse
there but hey we fighting back that gals
good and then like a little like what
you know yeah exactly right that's
that's what that's what Hitler did yeah
that's what Hillary started with like
hey you know we don't want to have this
happening yeah can we got to keep these
things in check yeah yeah look we're
gonna at least we're gonna we're gonna
put the Jews in a neighborhood right
we'll put them in a separate
neighborhood that way they're not
amongst us right put them over there you
know and that's okay you know what we're
actually not going to moving somewhere
else
what would want to work camp okay and
then you just write you slowly
escalating yeah for your murdering to
six million people yeah all of a sudden
what you're not signed on all of a
sudden yeah and the thing in your thing
in your head you're like the anchor
signed on to some stuff earlier but I'd
let it go I'm trapped you know yeah
you're trapped and that's where he is
right now and he's trapped facing his
death by recognizing yeah recognizing
that yeah successively extracted the
German people from the best of the
commonly held European body of human
thought like you saying exactly what you
just said success successively it's just
a little bit at a time
back to the book all of us who wore a
uniform were entangled in a fabric of
developments and circumstances that we
certainly had not sought or desired now
well let's not make any excuses let's
not make any excuses but we see how it
kind of happened as you just said we
surely could not believe that our
employment here in Stalingrad was part
of a noble legitimate battle for German
infor interests painfully we felt that
the soldierly virtues of bravery
commitment loyalty and obedience to duty
in their objective sense were being
despicably misused this deepened the
tragedy of cruel events in which we now
would have to atone for much that we had
never wanted so yeah
that's you know I've heard that argument
sometimes if you well you're gonna kill
let there's a bad regime and you're
gonna go and you're gonna attack the
regime and then some of the people that
are just there by chance you know you
hear that argument well they're allowing
that regime to exist now that's a tough
argument to have because you've got
somebody for them to rebel could mean
death and so they don't get they don't
Rebelle and so they and then they in a
bad situation that's a tough one you
know fully but somebody asked me the
other day
so yeah it's along those lines you know
some long-winded question on Twitter
about what would you do if you were in
you know inside of a state that was Bob
all you know repressive and etc etc
knows like a one-word answer rebellion
now would I have the mentality that I
have right now is my growing up in one
of those repressive States probably not
if I just want to survive and get some
more bread yeah right I might not just
be thinking hey there's there's
something more important than me
and that's freedom and then maybe I
wouldn't think that maybe I'd just be
thinking hey I want some maybe I can get
an extra 20 grams of bread nope all
right back to the book in this is good
in the proximity of death things
appeared in their true light and proper
order in such a situation the Bible
speaks to us with an insistence in
clarity the like of which we had never
felt or understood before the fear and
misery at the edge of our existence had
given us a religious experience whose
strength giving power bound us together
so he's starting to see relate you
there's no atheist in a foxhole guess
what
according to wieder that's a very
accurate statement among my favorite
books in the little private library I
had taken with me to the Eastern Front
was a copy of Marcus Aurelius self
observations
- had often found support and comfort in
it it had contributed markedly to
completing my equipment for war by
serving me as a suit of armor that
protected me from all-too-frequent
woundings by events and giving me an
inner equi nominee now this book - like
several others had become meaningless
the wisdom of the world the wisdom of
the world with its merely human temporal
comfort had failed it did not penetrate
into the ultimate and most profound and
could no longer stand firm in the
terrible shock and helplessness whose
mercy I felt myself to be in in extreme
distress with the ground shaking under
foot and a menacing abyss of nothingness
seeming to open before me there was only
one last support the comforting strength
of the Christian belief perhaps we could
pass some of this comfort and support on
to other comrades who bewildered were
reeling toward the abyss in their
desperation faced with the destruction
of a whole world of concepts and in a
view of the senseless senselessness of
the catastrophe many a soldier on the
staffs as well as within the fighting
troops had reached for his pistol to put
an end to his life there was no way back
and no escape other disguised their
secret fear and inner feelings of
emptiness behind a contrived soldierly
stance or even deliberately assumed to
the cast of mind of a languished necked
which is like these guys were these
old-school German mercenaries that were
super hardcore if they themselves were
doomed to go under they would at least
sell their skin so dearly to the end and
take as many Russians with them as they
could now that's interesting
he's he's projecting on these soldiers
that you know that they're disguising
their secret fear do you know what I'm
telling you right now that some of those
Nazi German soldiers they were they were
getting after
right they weren't they weren't to
hiding their their secret fear by acting
tough they were ready to die for the
Fuhrer mm-hmm so let's not just paint
with a broad brush there in my opinion
if we agreed that suicide was out of the
question for religious and ethical
reasons as normal weak human beings
caught up an error and guilt there was
nothing left to to us but to drink the
cup of suffering to the last bitter
dregs you know in the meantime something
unbelievable happened and made quickly
made the rounds our quartermaster a
still young general staff officer
suddenly disappeared his driver who had
taken to the gun rack airbase had waited
in vain for his return the Lieutenant
Colonel was missing he had silently left
Stalingrad left the Stalingrad pocket
the zone of death and destruction on his
own initiative probably it was a mixture
of nerves fear cowardice and the vain
hope than in the general confusion he
might be able to fly out and save his
life that had tempted him to desert the
commanding general had made inquiries by
radio the deserting staff officer had
shown up an army group claiming the
flown out unofficial assignment from the
Corps on matters of supply our general
was wild with indignation and rage
declared that he would have the criminal
flown back into the pocket and shot
before our eyes we were all deeply
depressed and into with an anticipated
with horror the terrible scene that had
been announced and which we were spared
to our relief our quartermaster was shot
outside the pocket on the spot where in
his fatal weakness he had hoped to find
a door to freedom in life so again even
though I just talked about some of the
Nazis being committed to the end there
was many of them that were just trying
to get the hell out of there back to the
book our commanding general spoke openly
of the impending collapse accusingly
with bitterness and secret anger he
pointed out that it was not our fault we
had gotten into this devilís situation
of a catastrophe from which there was no
longer a means of escape okay
here he is the commanding general is now
saying hey look this is not our fault so
he he so clearly he's obviously not
taking any ownership of this but okay so
it's only ask you this okay Jocko what
would how would it help him if he was to
take ownership of it right now right if
he was to say hey this is my fault would
it help him could if you say hey look
this is my fault this is why this
happened would that help him right now
no you're right it wouldn't help them
would it have helped him a month or two
months ago if he said to himself look
we're in this situation I need to take
ownership of it and get it fixed would
it have helped then you're damn right it
would've he said you know what
Hitler might in that town might be
telling us not to break out guess what
Hitler's not here we're gonna break out
I'll go get shot for defying his orders
that's fine I'll save all of you that's
that's where ownership would have come
in but what he said was look what we're
assigned to our fate I talk about this
all the time just because the boss tells
you or doesn't give you the support that
you need or gives you a bad order that
doesn't give you the excuse you can't
put the ownership on the boss you're the
one in charge you take ownership of it
you get the problem solved he didn't do
that so he he's no I don't want to say
allowed to say it's not our fault but he
okay him saying it's not our fault is a
kind of a different circumstance why
because they're past the point of no
return because they're doomed already
yes because they don't have any you know
you take responsibility and then take
responsibility for the fixing the
mistakes there is no fixing mistakes
anymore that's why if I was him yeah I
would have said hey guys it's not your
fault that you're here this is my fault
I should have made a maneuver I should
have stood up to the boss
I didn't here's what we're gonna do now
to defend ourselves the best of our
ability right right so then that would
still give the guys some breathing room
right some psychological breathing room
yeah they fought hard they did their
best it's my fault I should have I
should have held you guys do something
different and I didn't here's what we're
gonna do now the fact that he that these
that he wasn't taking ownership earlier
yeah the fact that he's able to blame
now
means he was able to blame earlier and
if you're but the minute you start
blaming you're not solving anything
you're not getting things done there you
go yeah back to the book but he left no
doubt that together we still had a task
to perform named eater namely to fulfill
our soldierly duty duty to the last
moment in obedience to the orders from
above we would defend our perimeter
fighting shoulder to shoulder with our
carbines to the last bullet from his
words we could surmise that he was
staunchly determined to go down like a
captain with his ship and not to survive
the downfall of his troops unequivocally
he pointed out that the commandments of
the traditional ethical code of the
soldier now demanded our ultimate
sacrifice without Damir now at this
point he's supposed to go out and do a
do like a reconnaissance of the lines
and see what's going on and when he's up
there here's what he sees in freezing
cold and wild snow for your flurries I
rode across the desolate battlefield on
a motorcycle together with a sergeant of
the military police we soon reached a
road of catastrophic we soon reached the
road of catastrophe arising dark gray
against the backdrop of a snowbound
steppe marked by all kinds of abandoned
rubbish half covered cadavers of horses
and wrecked vehicles scattered pieces of
equipment crates destroyed weapons that
dispersed the starving the freezing the
sick but all those still fit for
fighting had only one objective to which
they were attaching their last
glimmerings of hope and this objective
was Stalingrad in the protective walls
of the cellars of the ruins they might
still be able to find some warmth food
rest sleep and salvation and so they
streamed by the remains of the shattered
and decimated formation trains and rear
echelon services with vehicles that were
slowly being dragged and pushed by
wounded sick and frostbitten men there
were emaciated figures among them
muffled and coats rags pitiful wrecks
painfully dragging themselves forward
leaning on sticks and hobbling all along
the fro on frozen feet
than wisps of straw and strips of
blankets drifting along through the
snowstorm
this was the wreck of the sixth army
that had advanced to the Volga during
the summer so confident of victory men
from all over Germany doomed to
destruction in a far-off land newly
enduring their suffering tottered and
pitiful drove droves through the
murderous eastern winter these were the
same soldiers who had formerly marched
through the large parts of Europe's as
proud conquerors now the enemy was at
their backs and death lurked everywhere
there's a interesting piece that I don't
go into too much but this guy had
written a paper and presented it up the
chain of command with talking about what
happened to Napoleon and he got kind of
told like hey that's not gonna happen to
us back to the book the events of 1812
seem to be repeating themselves after
all once again the uncanny Russian space
was swallowing many tens of thousands of
human beings
despite Napoleon's experience the basic
elements of geography and meteorology
had again been ignored to a frightening
degree on top of that the modern
superstition that with the help of
machines and motors the impossible could
be accomplished and the dangers of space
overcome had also contributed to our
downfall and in a fatal pact with the
overestimation of mechanized means of
war had stood the misapprehension of the
limits of human strength and
possibilities yeah repeat
yeah that was another one of those
classic lines that's not gonna happen us
oh yeah I mean it feels like yeah you
know that's a classic mistake it's
called ego called lack of humility mmm
don't worry that won't happen to us it
happened to Napoleon one of the greatest
you know military leaders of all time
but it won't happen us cuz we have some
cars we got some tanks or whatever but
by the way tanks tank fuel where's that
fuel gonna come from I mean at least a
horse can eat a piece of hay right sure
you know there there's no Exxon station
out there on the steps back to the book
together with several wounded we dragged
ourselves onwards until exhausted and
shattered we finally reached the ruins
of rubble of northern Stalingrad City
area so now he's actually was retreating
back to Stalingrad itself what travails
did fate still hold in store for us
death who might faced more often and
closely in recent days than ever before
was still refusing me but his trusted
companion for many weeks hunger was
tormenting me with tenacious power
slowly making me ripe for the end and
frost the third murderer and the trio
had also bitten me by now as the
constant stabbing pains and some of my
limbs warned me separated from our staff
our group of officers found shelter in a
dark dirty cellar while our men went to
ground in a neighboring pile of rubber
rubble this was to be the end of our
flight and our last quarters the army
had once again addressed itself to okay
H and pointing adamantly to the
catastrophic situation had asked for
immediate permission to surrender which
might possibly prevent still complete
disillusion dissolution and total
disaster
Hitler's answer had been a steely no
forbid surrender Hitler and radiodns in
the pocket on 25 January the army will
hold its position to the last man and
bullet
imagine being that freezing hungry
tortured by the enemy at your back and
you got some guy in a bit a nice
ridiculous it's one thing to be like
yeah we're going to the last one the
last bullet and it's this big war but it
lasts me you know I don't know a week
not even a week you know like that one
big last stand we're gonna fight to the
death that's one thing and I dig it and
that's you know but just weeks and weeks
and weeks of just slowly dying of
starvation and sickness and that's way
different it's way different to try to
fight till the last man and the last
bullet in that scenario yeah especially
because they they all kind of know that
there's no strategic advantage on what
they're doing even worse back to the
book colonel-general Paulus and his
chief of staff who's fanatical will to
hold out was well known among the staffs
relentlessly held on to their fatal
decision from their part many generals
and their staffs remain the
executioner's of the orders of
destruction under these sorry
circumstances for fighting suffering and
dying continued torturing Lee and
terribly after the splitting of the
pocket the death agony of the army
continued for a further week in the
general dissolution and catastrophe it
was every man for himself more and more
order and discipline broke down here and
there in the cellars the still
able-bodied in combat worthy hid among
the sick and wounded cases of uncle rod
early conduct theft of provisions
refusal to obey orders and open mutiny
mounted filleted the elementary drive of
self-preservation no longer allowed the
question of right or wrong to be raised
and in the same way that the differences
between the front line and rear line
Ashland the rear echelon were being
erased so were the differences in rank
and the
in the final days summary law was
imposed in Stalingrad with drastic
punishments for any crime looters were
to be shot within 24 hours hundreds of
German soldiers who had become weak in
their misery thus became victims of
German bullets one could no longer
generally speak of courageous and heroic
fighting certainly here and there there
were individual deeds of courage
personal initiative and noble self
self-sacrifice but by and large only a
mute submission to the inescapable fate
remained to the bitter end it was rather
the silent heroism of acceptance of
suffering and submitting not the picture
that gets painted very often now at this
point at this point right now in this
battle is when they hear that speech
that Goering said talking about this
great sacrifice and how they fought so
well and how they'll be remembered
forever and compared him to Leonidas and
the 300 Spartans at Thermopylae it's
just that here's what these guys thought
with over exaggerated feverish pathos
the speaker recalled the heroic example
of the last of the Goths and in the end
the historical so famous sacrifice of
the Spartan heroes at Thermopylae
who had not fought faltered or given
ground until the last fighter had fallen
and so it was at Stalingrad just like
Leonidas and his loyal men in the Greek
defile so with the German heroes lie on
the Volga as the law of Honor and
conduct in war commanded them to do for
Germany during this speech full of empty
phrases and lies that outdid itself in
hysterical glorification and praises the
demeanor of the deeply delusion and
incensed audience became more and more
hostile the glances gestures and words
all around unmistakably showed the rage
that was growing
people's souls whoever might still have
trusted in the promise of help from the
outside now had to recognize with
growing horror that at home we're
relatives still hope for a union the
Warriors of Stalingrad had finally been
written off we felt that we had heard
our own funeral oration before its time
the disgusting adulation of the
torturers dying of our army and the
deceitful glorification of conditions
that were against all laws of humanity
filled me with indignation and revulsion
must not going warnings words have
pierced the hearts of our loved ones at
home like daggers and robbed them of all
hope now that they had been thrown into
the most anxious fears of art for our
lives at home we had been declared dead
the hero is a ssin and mythical
glorification of our Stalingrad army was
supposed to conceal the sad truth for a
long time now the heroic tale of the
German soldier on the Volga had become
an irresponsible mass dying ordered from
on high the pathetic propaganda of
glorification was obviously intended to
distract from the catastrophic
consequences of a criminally amateur
ously der ship of war and to prevent the
question of blame from even arising
so you pretty much see how these guys
felt at the end and now you might think
you might think that there's a
disconnect between Hitler like heip
we're proud we're fighting to the end
and this is the way that Germans are and
this is the way that we are we're
superior and that the guys on the ground
now they're just beat down and so maybe
they're just maybe they're just weak
right and they're just giving up you
might think that you might think that
here's this will give you a little
indication that that that's the wrong
thought on the one February the news
spread among us that Paulus had
capitulated with his staff and the two
southern segments of the pocket and gone
into captivity so of a leader just
surrendered at the last moment he'd been
promoted to Field Marshal this promotion
in the hour of the final catastrophe was
grotesque it was simply a gesture of
thanks from above and a goodbye so
Hitler thought Paulus was gonna die
well he didn't Paulus surrendered but
the unhappy Field Marshal Marshall did
not set the example of heroism expected
of him from the top the German papers
broadcasts later broadcasts later tried
to spread the impression the style of
Goering speech that in the face of
overwhelming superiority the field
marshal had burned his secret papers and
that the generals lying behind their
machine guns had fought to the end
furthermore after the catastrophe German
magazines lied to the German people with
faked pictures so showing such heroic
scenes but the truth of the matter was
something quite else we calculated that
more than 15 generals and their staffs
had gone into captivity from the
southern and central pockets soon Moscow
soon the Moscow radio gave details of
numbers and names
I was only to learn later that some of
these generals had gone into captivity
with neatly packed suitcases and
plentiful baggage they simply stop
fighting and gave themselves up to the
victor without any further consider
for the fate of the remaining
battlegroups the last request of the
Field Marshal had been that the Russians
should treat him as a private citizen
with this he had resigned the official
role he had formerly played in the
military political interests of the
Supreme Commander and as a broken man
laid down his martial ship he was driven
away in a closed car and no longer
needed to see the appalling misery of
his sacrificed army so there's no
disconnect the troops on the ground were
right these leaders were liars weak and
they had no problem pursuing glory with
someone else's ass but they weren't
ready to deal with their own deep down
inside I had increasingly begun to
oppose certain military concepts of
obedience honor and discipline like
those that had been manifesting
themselves to the end in the measures
taken by our command was this only the
so this is this is weak he went through
all this and he's like only now he's
starting to oppose some of some of his
his military concepts of obedience if
this is was an American the Americans
are rebellious by nature like we don't
we don't you know if you if you're
leading us down the wrong path we stand
up and say like no you're not gonna do
that
stop no he's you know here going well
they've done all this and only now am I
starting to question these things and he
even questions his question back to the
book was this only the revolt of my
selfish instinct for self-preservation
was an only an unsold early stance fear
or cowardice at a time when things had
become bitterly serious precisely at
this point I again remembered the
awkward deeply penetrating thoughts and
feelings with which I had asked myself
at the beginning of the war why and for
whom must you make this sacrifice
the same questions that had never really
taken root rose again before me gigantic
ly and applicable to the whole army was
there really a noble high holy objective
at stake here insulin grad in our and in
our battle an ethically justified goal
which could be served by ultimate human
human test of giving one's life did
soldierly honor and obedience to orders
really justify this demand so casually
made of us that we hold out for this
lost cause this excess of suffering and
dying was this immeasurable sacrifice
really decisive for the outcome of the
war and could it serve our country and
our people this is what this is you
wanna know why we talk about the why all
the time there it is yeah now he should
have been asking that question a long
time ago hmm and he said he started to
in the beginning he started to ask that
question but he didn't go through with
it you know why cuz they were winning
they were winning it's easy don't really
need to know why whenever you go out
there you know beat this country beat
that country roll through that country
it's pretty easy not getting tested back
to the book a foreboding I had long held
grew into a terrible certainty what was
happening here in Stalingrad was a
tragic senseless self-sacrifice a
scarcely credible betrayal of the final
commitment and devotion of brave
soldiers our our innocent trust had been
misused in the most despicable manner by
those responsible for the catastrophe we
had been betrayed led astray and
condemned the men of Stalingrad were
dying in betrayed belief and in betrayed
trust in my heart the bitter feeling of
and all for nothing became ever more
torturing in my soul arose again the
whole abysmal disaster of the war itself
more clearly than ever I appreciated the
full measure of misery and wretchedness
of the other countries in Europe to
which German soldiers and German arms
had brought boundless misfortune so he's
reflecting and he's looking around
saying look what we did
these other countries had we not so far
the victors been all too prone to close
our eyes and our hearts and to forget
that always and everywhere the issues
were living human beings their
possessions and their happiness so like
you said he turned a blind eye he rolled
through all these countries he did all
that evil probably only a few among us
had entertained the fault of the
sufferer of the thought that the
suffering and dying being caused by our
sorry profession of war would one day be
inflicted upon us we had carried our
total war into one region of Europe
after another and thereby destructively
interfered with the destinies of foreign
nations far too little we had asked the
reason why the necessities and
justifications for what was happening or
reflected on the immeasurable 'ti of our
political responsibility that these
entailed misery and death had been
initiated by us and now we were
inexorably coming home to roost they
were inexorably coming home to roost the
step on the dawn and the volca had
drunks streams of precious human blood
the Russians were certainly also making
cruelly high blood sacrifices in the
murderous battle of stalingrad but they
who were defending their country against
a foreign aggressor knew better than we
why they were risking their lives
so yeah the Russians they're fighting
they're dying for sure but they know
that they're defending their homeland
it's a lot easier for them to understand
many officers and commanders now began
to oppose the insane orders and
emanating from the Fuhrer headquarters
and being passed on by army command by
this they they began to reject the long
eroded military concepts of honor and
discipline to which the army leadership
had clung until the end in the
unconditional obedience such such as was
fatally being upheld here in Stalingrad
there was no longer a soldierly stance
but rather
a lack of responsibility so I say that
one more time
this idea that unconditional obedience
was was was not seen right now as a
soldierly stance but a lack of
responsibility because you are
responsible to do something if if you're
getting batterers you're responsible for
not obeying them and you know I get
asked this question all the time
not all the time but you know sometimes
people say what if you got you know what
did you do if you ever got told
something that you didn't believe it was
like well we were on the same page like
it's not like we were getting told to do
things that were immoral unethical you
know they weren't saying hey go burn
this village with women and children it
we weren't getting those orders you know
what I mean we weren't getting told to
do things that that weren't that I
didn't agree with that my guys didn't
agree with and and that's the way the
Milich are there are there pockets where
things happen yeah absolutely that's
what that's the horrors of war but if we
got told to do things that we didn't
think we should do we would've said no
not doing it hmm this was open mutiny so
they've gotten to the point now finally
since there were no more orders from the
center towards the end many responsible
commanders and unit leaders on the line
acted on their own initiative in an
endeavor to stop the senseless shedding
of blood many desperate Stalingrad
warriors in the end sought a way out by
suicide or by voluntary by a voluntary
soldiers death we learned of two
generals who extremes whose extreme
resolution had been shattering one the
commander of a division from Dresden had
shot himself after having ordered his
son a young lieutenant to report to him
the safe farewell the other the
commander of a division from lower
saxony whose tactical emblem was a
four-leaf clover and was known therefore
as the lucky division who did not want
to survive the downfall of his men had
been killed on the front line while
standing erect and firing his weapon
the last pockets of resistance what was
left of about six shattered divisions
and the remnant of other formations that
had meanwhile been left to their fate by
the resignation of the Army Command now
had to bear the whole burden of the
concentrated air attacks artillery and
mortar fire it was not only the fear of
the coming end the hunger clawing at my
intestines and the pain from my frozen
limbs that turned the last seemingly
endless hours in the Stalingrad pocket
into the tortures of hell for me the
proximity of death toward the last
obscuring vales from my eyes and brought
fruits of long years of individual
experiences observations tormenting
feelings and thoughts into an instant
maturity now on the very edge of being
war in its for us most terrible form
became the inexorable revealer of all
things he's going through like spiritual
awakening as he faces death in my mind's
eye the horrible experiences and
pictures of destruction that would not
leave me in peace by day or night were
strung together in a bloody chain
experience as an impression stretching
far into the past that suddenly awoke in
my sharpened memory I discovered to be
logically connected links of this fatal
chain when it formerly always caused me
to have nasty premonitions and
apprehensions what had always disquieted
me I now suddenly had a recognized as
having been the warning of a fatal
fundamental evil the dimensions of which
I had thought not thought possible
now faced with the eminently impending
catastrophe the question about the sense
of what was happening it plagued me so
often during the war seized me again
with cruel force hundreds of thousands
of flowering human lives were suddenly
being census Li stuffed out here in
Stalingrad what an immeasurable wealth
of human happiness human plans hopes
talents fertile possibilities for the
future were thereby being destroyed
forever the criminal insanity of an
irresponsible war management with its
superstitious belief in technology and
its utter lack of feeling for the life
value and dignity of man and here
prepared for us a hell on earth how
could the long eroded concepts of Honor
duty obedience soldierly heroism figure
any longer into our feelings thoughts
and actions to stay alive to be reunited
once again with our loved ones at home
this burning desire was now the drive
behind all thoughts and actions
gradually we had a custom that ourselves
to the to the idea of surrendering at
the first opportunity and going into
Russian captivity in the end I basically
had only one wish to stay alive and
healthy and go into captivity unwounded
so that's it goes into captivity
you know after going through a I don't
know if you want to call it a spiritual
awakening of recognizing that his whole
life had been doing something evil yeah
in the is it's pretty anti-climatic how
it happens how they get how they end up
in captivity back to the book in the
early minutes of captivity I felt an
easing tension and and
in the end the insecurity of our
situation between life and death had
weighed down on all of us like led what
first attracted my attention so now
they're captured what first attracted my
attention imagine this was the fresh
healthy appearance of the victors their
simple enviable winter clothing and good
weapons Sun submachine guns everywhere
and the uniform picture of sheep skins
padded jackets felt boots and fur caps
with broad earmuffs swinging up and down
the warmly bundled up well nourished and
splendidly equipped men of the Red Army
with their chunky mostly red cheek faces
formed a stark contrast to our deathly
pale filthy bearded and freezing figures
of misery who hung exhausted and sick
and their makeshift winter clothing
consisting of all kinds of furs blankets
scarfs filled grey headgear wounds an
inadequate foot gear this sudden meeting
and comparison at once showed me how low
we had sunk and how little we had been
prepared for this murderous battle then
the Soviets kind of the Russians kind of
have their shots Adam fritzy fascist
Hitler kaput they alternated threats and
obviously dreadful Kurt curses and
contemptuous spit like raging Wolf's
vengeful soldiers from the rear echelon
fell on the helpless victims time and
time again to steal personal baggage and
to vent their spleen so now they're
captured in the the Russians start to
kind of sing and dance and and singing
old folk songs back to the book all the
noise and exuberance surrounding me
formed a shrieking contrast to the inner
and outer state which I found myself
torn from my circle of comrades left to
myself and my emotions in the midst of
the joyful dancing and singing victors
with whom no contact could be
established in my inner heart I
felt abandoned and without hope totally
depressed uprooted cut off from home
sunk far away subjugated to a foreign
will pit asleep piteously thrown to the
mercy of an unknown powers to be
dependent on the whim of the victor
constantly watched menacingly surrounded
by barbed wire guns forced to
relinquished any kind of external
freedom captivity meant on an unknown
form of human submission and humiliation
it is a bounty for us human beings that
a merciful hand covers the future from
our eyes with an impenetrable veil
that's a really great line had I known
then that I was destined for more than
seven comfortless years devoid of love
and filled with previously unknown
mental and physical tortures and fearful
uncertainties on the borderline of life
I never would have found the strength to
say stand the sufferings of the initial
hard months of captivity he's saying if
you would have known what the future
held seven years he's about to be in
captivity for he would have even made it
through he would have given up and he
doesn't talk in this book about what
that imprisonment was like but he does
give what I think is a combination of
how he survived it and what he learned
from it going back to the book time and
again I was soothingly distracted from
my tormenting thoughts and dark visions
by the wonders of the brightly shining
star filled winter sky that appeared to
be so close to the touch that constantly
drew my eyes upwards as if by magical
force
what it so far appeared to me as the
downfall of a world come loose at the
seams and a catastrophe without bounds
suddenly took on measurable dimensions I
regained my equilibrium and found my way
back to myself where I had felt earlier
that chaos was swallowing me up now calm
and peace was flowing into my disquieted
heart the reconciling effect came from
the vast order and harmony that the
sparkling mass of bright stars with
their eternal laws of the universe
brought back to my attention anew the
consolation that the Stars sank into my
soul was strange and hardly to be
grasped by the intellect it seemed to me
as if my personal fate within the
framework of events on earth was
secretly included within the vast
all-embracing order of the cosmos for
the mass of survivors who had escaped
from the hell of stalingrad the
aftermath of the tragedy lasted only for
a short while they died in their tens of
thousands during the early months of
captivity hunger and deprivation frost
and sickness had already made them a
sure pray for death even before the
fighting stopped with the columns of
prisoners death also came to the various
camps of reception where terrible
epidemics raged everywhere an exact
accounting of the victims of stalingrad
according to numbers dates and
individual fates will never be made the
few that were allowed to begin a new
life at home and in freedom after long
years of captivity will always have to
ask themselves how they can justify the
deaths of the others by their own
existence how they can uphold and
fulfill the legacy of their dead
comrades but all Germany must also
loyally remember its many many sons that
lie at rest
in the distant Russian steppe and try
today and in the future to understand
their unforgettable sacrifice the
innumerable mounds of soldiers graves in
Stalingrad have long disappeared the
cemeteries were leveled soon after the
battle and partially converted to soccer
fields nothing is left of the army of
simple grey crosses but it is as if a
great invisible cross were rising there
on the Volga casting its shadow over our
nation and addressing penetrating
admonishing words to all of our hearts
and that closes out this book with with
some penetrating in admonishing words
for us because there's a lot of warnings
in this book warnings that we must pay
attention to and if we don't pay
attention to them then who will the
warnings the lessons here first of all
as a nation as a culture we have to look
at the way things fell apart in Germany
or maybe you look at the way things came
together slowly like we talked about the
traditional values were were move
designed and they were replaced with
these new values values that allegedly
protected the German citizens they were
values that were going to make the world
a better place
and it uses this term this political
religion that's a powerful thought
political religion took hold and then he
used that term presumptuous beliefs that
countered the foundation of their
existing cultures and beliefs so there's
some arrogance involved there we have
people that aren't even listening to the
counter-arguments I think we have to be
careful not to abandon the structures of
the past in some kind of a race to move
to the future because the future it
hasn't been tested by thousands and
thousands of years of human evolution
and I understand that we I'm not saying
we don't progress but I'm not saying we
don't evolve but I'm saying you don't
bow down and you don't submit you gotta
think about the direction that we're
heading and as citizens as people we
have to have the courage to stand up
before we reach the event horizon from
which there's no return so now on a
smaller level lessons from this book as
a as a person in business or in the
military or in any team as a subordinate
and we're also born to someone we have
to question our leaders and and I say
that all the time if we don't agree with
that plan or don't agree with the tactic
you you got to question your leadership
and you got to raise your hand but if we
know that the intent of our leadership
is malevolent or it's gonna cause
suffering human suffering on a grand
scale or on a minor scale you have to
we have to say no and do what is right
no matter the consequence no matter the
consequence and you know finally for us
as individuals we gotta remember that we
are in charge of our own lives we are
leading our own lives and where are you
leading yourself what are you doing that
you know you shouldn't be doing why are
you doing that
what attached Rafi are you heading
toward you don't have to be heading
towards that catastrophe you have the
opportunity to prevent catastrophe in
your own life but in order to do that
once again you have to stand up you have
to do the right thing you have to be
uncomfortable
you have to impose the discipline on
your own life so you don't have
something else imposed something bad
imposed so you don't have a catastrophe
imposed on your own life because when we
avoid the discomfort and when we avoid
the discipline and when we avoid doing
what we know is the right thing to do
that's when you end up in a personal
catastrophe in your own personal hell in
your own personal stalingrad you have to
do the hard thing the thing you know is
right and you know what is right and you
know what you are supposed to do
so do it and avoid going down a path
that leads to your own personal hell and
instead get on the path that leads to
freedom and I think that's all I've got
for tonight so
echo speaking of doing the right thing
sure maybe you could give us some ideas
on how we can you know continue down the
right path doing what we know we're
supposed to do the part where you said
you know you're less likely to raise any
questions or you're more likely to turn
a blind eye when you're winning roaming
set up I decided today like on the new
year's the boiler room am I wrong
no no you're right oh yeah yeah so the
guys there's a part where he's in there
waiting to go to a party
something you know they're selling
stocks yeah right and they're they're
like garbage stocks or whatever
inflating them yes they're like yeah all
this pump and dump
yeah and so they're in the car
going to some party in these like hey it
was it Giovanni whatever that his names
are they he's like hey he goes do you
ever wonder how we get these big
Commission's on these you know sigh and
he's like that's the wrong question to
ask you know he's like wait what do you
mean he's like he's like just just don't
ask that question basics she said don't
ask that question goes don't you like
the way things are going
he's like yeah but I do I do but don't
you ever wonder he's like no I like
being a millionaire same exact thing
when you're winning it's easy to turn
the blind eye you know good point
yeah man so I mean I guess that kind of
plan well yeah you know it's interesting
that you point that out and I think that
like on a personal level right let's say
you're doing really good yeah it's then
it can be tricky for people that
the right thing yes you because that's
why we see like these uh celebrity like
movie stars or celebrity athletes or
whatever man they do some dumb stuff
right the new some dumpster because
they're winning they're thinking they're
good you do whatever they want
yeah they make the wrong choice yeah
they're on the evening news doing dumb
stuff yeah that ruins them yeah and them
in their own personal stalingrad put in
hell you know yeah even yeah with money
too you know you know like and celebrity
types and you know athletes who even
just people people yeah yeah what a good
job in store their business blows up or
whatever yeah I guess yeah I guess
any type of winning we could look at
yeah it doesn't mean you're necessarily
doing the right thing yeah harder my
point is and I think you're saying the
same thing if it can be harder yeah to
do the right thing when you're winning
cuz you just think you're ya good to go
you get arrogant yeah yeah let's not
let's not put brakes on this train here
just let it all fly kind of thing yeah
and then when the Train kind of loses
momentum meanwhile all those those
things that you've been ignoring they're
still there
hey you know look at your empty bank
account you spent all that money you're
supposed to keep before you made my get
you our money you were budgeting you're
budgeting your survive you're budgeting
you're doing good you started making all
this money started spending all this
money well the money stopped coming in
your budget it's gone saying that's what
happens sometimes we can't happen yeah
also pay now or pay later I remember
that one that was a good one that you
said yeah did I say that
yeah pay now or pay later I think we're
talking about like working out or
something oh yeah are seriously I didn't
say it today though no no pay now or pay
later for sure nonetheless support yeah
for sure 100% good way to avoid going
down your personal uh it doesn't maybe
it doesn't nonetheless if you're in the
mood to support you don't end up in your
own personal stalingrad yeah right
but I don't know why supporting would
like prevent that you know no you know
no we could reach in creative deeper but
nonetheless you don't have any aversions
to reduce you were reaching deep today
to a solid rod training gay no those are
conceptually they were the same
they were I know the compare it's you
know most of these world most of these
like lessons I think I feel like they're
kind of everywhere yeah of course and
you know you talk about these heavy wars
yeah and heavy like events and then you
know in my mind I'm thinking to training
it you know what the you know the idea
still hates the same there's I think
there's people out there in various
states of mind sure and I think that you
know your perspective helps them maybe
get maybe see some what I'm saying
because maybe I'm hitting them from the
wrong angle so yeah you're coming in
from training day movies yeah hey man
yeah actually and come to think about it
these concepts right here today when
you're saying you know you know what
it's going to take for example when it's
going good it's easy to turn the blind
eye isn't that kind of a lot of movies
how it is it's like the guy does real
good and he's just kind of going and it
he messes up in one way or another but I
think there's a talk by Kurt Vonnegut
and I've seen it on YouTube
I think it's Kurt Vonnegut music
teaching a class you know Kurt Vonnegut
is yeah yeah he's teaching some class
like he just guest teaching in some
clothes pretty awesome but he's talking
about like there's four plot lines and
they're all pretty much this yeah yeah
yeah it's pretty cool I think but that's
what you're you you have nothing and
then you get everything yeah they kind
of abuse it kind of in there's then
there's you have nothing you get
everything you lose everything and then
you get everything back he just got this
it's like I forget them all but make
sense their common common story tonight
yeah and they must be kind of but I mean
it must be right based on real life like
like term like scenarios that you go
through well I think it's why there's
things like comeback story
yeah Ellis story comeback kid I mean
those things really exert dog still
underdog yeah triumphant yeah yeah
that's how nonetheless of you here in
the mood to support and you know between
your movie watching escapades is that
the correct word escapades yeah yeah
yeah yeah I don't recommend it I
recommend you read yeah
whatever you training day maybe we'll
get you there yeah that's a good one I
thought anyway nonetheless origin mean
isn't it weird that like training day is
this movie that caught how much the cost
to make training day I don't know 50
million dollars and like you go to the
library and get Stalin grab the book
yeah for nothing really nothing
yeah where you can buy it you can buy it
on Amazon for I think this book cost
like a dollar yeah it's not used but
it's just kind of a strange dichotomy
there it's interesting for sure and yeah
you know obviously we can go into line
which one is another for you I'm gonna
go ahead and say that Stalingrad is
better for you than training day well
depends on what you get out of it you
know you know how like I'm actually
people would ask me how do you read to
get the most out of it out of a book do
you well I read it while I'm reading it
I highlighted oh yeah Jordan B Peterson
I was watching something the others say
don't highlight anything yeah this is
this I have a major disagreement with
Jordan B Peterson I'm not highlight I'm
highlighting fool but anyway so I go
through I highlight what hits me and
then I go back and reread it and then I
have the red pen to circle the important
really on the Kindle if you can choose
your your color of highlighter so the
yellow is general highlighting and then
the orange yeah all right well how about
this we'll talk about some jujitsu keys
because people ask me yeah
what keys should I get you get origin
geez that's it in America from the
threads from the cotton that's always
say as we all know being America to the
shirt dirt to the shirt may be said that
field to finish no I just was up there I
was just up at the factory with Pete oh
yeah I caught the Facebook line on my
head on my monitor - this show is that -
shame I think it might be just like yeah
baby dirty shirt it might be filled to
finish hands in daylight
hands in daylight yeah but yeah make
some good stuff especially geese in
America like I said good
in jiu-jitsu I you know I had I have a
few geese
I have a few keys I'd only use any of
them except the origin ones gonna remain
calm that's where you can get your G for
jujitsu they also have rash cards
compression gear right and that's for
jiu-jitsu I think primarily but you can
use it for other stuff of course yeah
indeed big tent also chocolate some
supplements good supplements krill oil I
was talking to kids name is Josh from
Virginia Tech net training seemed a
couple times there and I think he was
here for you know a few exhibitor train
and you know so we talked about
somethings young he's 21 and he said oh
yeah I take fish oil I was like ding
that's good I'm crude oil is better than
fish oil I know this because my though I
told you why are in my points dad told
me all the benefits blah blah blah
nonetheless but he's taking joint
supplements at 21 he said no I don't
have problems with my joints but I just
want to maintain this joint situation as
I get older I was like well you're way
ahead of me son
so I give him some of your joint warfare
yeah that's good
piete piete from origin he needs joint
warfare he can feel it dissipate in the
day and like when I was was with was
with him he'd be you know at five
o'clock in the afternoon to come back I
hold on me right back everything takes
enjoy warfare
oh you that later he's at the threshold
yeah he's like that guy needs it yeah
it's yeah and that's actually it's
interesting because you know you can see
what's selling and what's cool is you
can see joint warfare krill oil like
what's awesome about is it 3p customers
of people that order it then they order
it again and then they ordered again
yeah because you don't want it if you're
not feeling it yeah that's what I'm
that's how I am with the krill oil yeah
100% like if you like I'll forget it'll
be like you know like oh I'll take it
later I don't forget that yeah I know
you know you're just you have a more
routine and whatever and that's the
thing that's the thing doesn't include
just wake up boom-boom-boom from a
medicine cabinet open all my stuff is
right there no and it not to go too deep
into my routine but during the week it's
you know wake up and then there's like
my daughter's four and a half she has
school so there's that situation going
on this is not my this does not
interfere with you getting up and taking
some pills for before you brush your
teeth kind of not see that's the thing
the routine doesn't allow for me to take
them before I know it's part it's the
routine man
it's the routine for the routine cuz
from after you gotta you got it you
gotta take the pills before you brush
your teeth because when you brush your
teeth you got that strong mint in there
that makes the water like too cold and
your teeth yeah see and I like that I
think it's more refreshing now see maybe
I need to harden up a little bit maybe
Jack probably nonetheless sometimes I
forget 3/4 and you if you forget for
like 4 days and you're still working out
or whatever you'll feel it I will feel
it so same thing Kroy I need it yeah I
had leaf actually actually Jenna Jenna
brought me krill oil you know I know
that bro
that's ok krill oil bring me some yeah
you know I don't want to do that but
probably that's important yeah another
seven panic mode yeah nonetheless vector
krill oil chakras krill oil super krill
has a super it's super krill it's not
normal cream super and there's many
reasons for that you find out on the
website or domain.com if you want to
know those exact reasons also joint
warfare that's for your joints maintain
your your body structure while your work
you know good call because it does uh
dissipate I don't want to use it or
dissipate but what do you call
degenerate did generate sure after time
when you when you go hard in the paint
mm-hmm unless like I said they got
compressing your G's rash guards oh
stuff hoodies which may or may not be
the most comfortable hoodies and pants
by the way the sweat pants joggers
apparently joggers yeah so the other day
I'm like okay I'm exporting some special
effect that I did so I'm like shoot when
you export it's like
you can't really use that program you
know you can x-ray me it's a long story
but so I'm like okay I'm off my computer
for you know it's gonna take like 10
minutes a big effect so I gotta lay on
the couch and have the whole origin on
for whatever reason just kind of
happened you i'll and the couch I'm like
dang I don't think I've felt this
comfortable in a long time but it was
everything let's come that's that's
pretty bold statement level of comfort
come I mean comfort seeker 100% and I
evaluate you evaluate various comfort
level levels I've been one of the
highest I get it it was everything it
was the couch it was the time of day it
was the fact that he lay around
we lived with one of my seal buddies for
many years we were kind of just just
young dumb wrong man we had this yellow
couch that was like 14 feet long you get
it was gonna tell it was like maybe five
feet deep it's like a bed no
realistically it was like five feet deep
what's one you through the back cushions
off it was five feet deep and it was
probably 12 12 feet long and where was
this in um in our parking your apartment
yeah he was gold it was a gold felt yeah
I mean we got it from some job yeah
that's the kind you have been like a
lousy dollars we had one like that at
you ate you know in the football lounge
yeah it was like it wasn't those bad cos
you know you know that couch you were
looking at tonight in my house you're
like yeah that's a nice couch it this
think that couch out there you're all
nice doesn't even come close to the
comfort of the old gold couch yeah it
was the deal yet weirdo like ugly like
couches will be the most functionally
comfortable we had this one my wife
forced us to give boy and because it was
outside he got phased out slowly you
know how you get a new couch and you
know okay we're gonna do there I'm not
gonna give it away no because it's too
comfortable we've had it for so long and
it's like in good shape oh and then we
get another couch for the you know for
the side there or when we do this so so
it ends up outside you know anyone's can
count
couch outside it's like it's kind of you
know doesn't does it look good bah blah
blah gave it away but it was the most
comfortable couch I think we actually
know the new I don't know what I'm
talking about
nonetheless doctor Origen go to origin
mean calm that's it that's where you get
it and you can get the discipline there
too yeah yeah yeah the discipline big
time the pre-workout the pre-mission the
pre-mission the pre-mission yeah shit it
to me I take it before a workout see I
don't I take it before I do Jitsu yeah
well I take it before I have to do a
podcast or I take it before I have to do
like a like a speaking event where I
need to do it my brain has to be firing
yeah yeah shake it before bed I mean I
know it has a little bit caffeine but
like I have and I think you can't I
don't think I'd strongly recommend it
especially if your caffeine sensitive
like I am sensitive but you drink your
9:00 Monster energy drinks a day you can
drink whatever you want from you taco
white tea because there's a lot less
caffeine well that you figured that she
saw a lot of you know a lot of people
hit me have used jock white tea to wean
off of a full-strength
coffee yeah yeah guys they don't want to
be on that coffee but there's enough you
need caffeine ain't it a little
something to wean off it's like
methadone getting off heroin so you
might want to try that but you know the
jock awaiting you and have coffee breath
anymore yeah cuz no one likes that yeah
it's really it's really not like
methadone but since the the pre-workout
pre-mission has cognitive enhancers you
figure you know when you sleep that's
like the best part of your brain is over
best time for your brain to recover
maybe that's a little something I don't
recommend it because like I said but you
never know could be could be something I
wouldn't drink it before I go to bed
maybe when you wake up yeah but I don't
drink when I wake up I'll drink it
because I don't drink it for I don't
drink any kind of pre workout for before
I work out before I lift weights before
I do a metcon I don't maybe I should I
don't know and you know one of the
reasons because I don't like to have
anything in my stomach when I'm working
out yeah but those pre workouts is like
yeah I know it's like really anything
right it's just like water like why
don't ya yeah maybe I'll try it
tell me report back please okay will do
yes sir
also speaking of work you know I get my
Kido kettlebells from on it and come /
chocolates we can get them kettlebells
the designer way you don't have to get
the designer ones I know I always say
the designer ones get the designer ones
and I'm still saying it mm Oh big time
see you don't have to but nonetheless on
it they have cool other cool workout
stuff you want your workout to be
creative telling you like you know the
you know the Mase right one of those I
have I do yeah you're done like a
workout with a mace yeah yeah I
incorporate them my name for I've got to
mace exercises what one of them is
called like can I have notes in my
notebook on what my workout you're gonna
have like barbarian smash that's the
word no no that's the movement oh okay I
think made up there and then ones like a
battle-axe swing sure so yeah yeah it's
like you can do is with the mace yeah
and it mace is heavy though well my race
is 20 pounds yeah that's heavy
oh yeah 20 pounds that's almost a
baseball bat way I don't know I don't
know couple pounds yeah and then you can
put I saw 16 ounce weight the other day
for the end of your bat when you're
getting warmed up a mace is 20 pounds
yes it's really heavy and the to me
really careful
actually yeah beak time yeah be careful
you don't expect that much weight on a
mound of mace with that weird cuz a 20
pound dumbbell you think oh that's
better 20 but that's not even part of
the workout I don't warm up with 20
pounds in any exercise kind of attitude
and then you're like so light then you
pick up that Mason you're like this is
like the heaviest stick I've ever beheld
for sure yeah in stick form other stuff
too it's really cool
so go on a duck on slash jaco and check
it out get something also subscribe to
the podcast itunes google play stitcher
anywhere there were they broadcast a
podcast
broadcast podcasts yeah Spotify -
confirmed boom do it also youtube if you
want the video version of this podcast
if you want to see what chocolate looks
like
you're into that kind of stuff look on
YouTube also have excerpts on there
actually someone emailed me and said
just for the excerpts it a thanks for
putting excerpts on there that's pretty
cool
that is pretty cool to be like yeah just
a this is cool so obviously it's a good
thing there are excerpts on there that's
a good thing because sometimes the
podcast goes a little long yeah this is
specially this section no I think you're
two hours of reading that's reading some
book nonetheless YouTube some value
there I think if you you know you watch
certain people they play put in there
you to your live some point yeah on the
YouTube beyond our YouTube channel yeah
even more value send you an alert right
I think yeah yeah if you're subscribed
yeah if you allow the alert and you're
subscribed and you can yeah it's good no
less you do good way to support also
Jaakko has a store it's called Chacko
store Jaakko store.com that's where you
can get all the cool shirts they're cool
I think to cool all the shirts
discipline equals freedom get after it
there's even the shirt that jockle wears
every single day in his life the victory
sure it's available you can get it you
can get it out on also rash guards on
there some cool stuff women's stuff on
their hoodies patches hats you know what
I'm gonna make this commitment right now
I'm gonna put something new every single
what you're not like cause that
committee I don't know every month I'll
put something new can people have an IOU
to tell you what they want no actually
yes actually I like that or maybe the
email yeah email through the store or
Twitter or whatever the PM we do it
everyone does for sure
this lot of stuff is suggestions
actually a lot of existing already
exactly heavier-duty sweatshirts hats
yep follow babies beneath you know
they're on the way yes oh yeah they're
in look like for sure hundred yeah
that's a suggestion yeah these are all
people suggestions from the field yeah
say that yeah so yeah it takes
suggestions big
I kind of I pull the trigger on the ones
that have the most suggestions so
sometimes I understand you know if
you're like hey I made a suggestion and
I still have my suggestion you know
you're in the field too and I dig it but
if you're the only one sorry I'm sorry
no pull over here yeah not that much
though unless anyway chuckle store.com
that's a place also psychological
warfare if you don't know what that is
here's what it is it's an album that you
can buy on iTunes Amazon music Google
Play anywhere where you can buy mp3
downloads it's an album that you can buy
with tracks chocolate tracks and is what
it's for it's not means it's not chalk
with singing or playing guitar what else
do you play ukulele now yeah you could
later I bet you yeah they you can't so
jocks not playing that he's he's
speaking to you pragmatic he's giving us
us pragmatic advice on why or how I
would say how to overcome certain points
of weakness in our campaigns against
weakness that's what it is so you know
you want to skip the workout you want to
cheat on the diet or it isn't you're
compelled to one day because you're
feeling not enough tired if you run into
little speed bumps your campaign listen
to this to the track for everything
trust me just look at it what if instead
of somebody wanting to watch training
day they want to read one of these books
where could they get them and what's the
best way to shop for them while
supporting this podcast go ahead you ask
I got the solution right now this is
what I did if you didn't know already
here's what I did go to Chaco podcast
calm chuckle podcast calm not the store
podcast website they organized all the
books by episode in section called books
from the podcast click through there
actually that's a good way to support
two takes and Amazon Amazon Prime get
the book in like two days
boom and it supports the podcast
big-time good word things whatever you
like man long lawnmowers duct tape what
else
rubber duckies if you have kids you know
what else you can get on amazon.com is
you can get dark a white tea
when you get it also order yourself some
new weights because upon drinking Chaka
white tea you will be able to deadlift
8,000 pounds certified you oh you got
some new weights didn't you yeah I did
all right we'll leave it at that
it's all good it happens you can also
get some books some books from you know
that I've kind of put together the one
of them is called weigh the warrior kid
that book teaches kids to do the right
things in their lives study read work
out eat clean help others work hard get
tons of feedback on that book because it
helps kids they relate to it speaking of
related to it there's a little warrior
kid out there 12 years old the name is
Aiden he reached out to me wanted he
make soap from goat milk you hear the
story yes makes any hear the whole story
okay he makes so for goat milk you know
why he makes soap from goat milk you
can't do anything with goat milk in
California you can't sell it to someone
because it's not edible or whatever they
have a place right the regs in place
what do you do with goat milk then he
didn't know what to do with it then he
figured out I'll make soap and then he
wanted to make good soap yeah and so he
said hey can I make some choco soap and
I was like yeah dude you're 12 years old
get after it
and he did Irish Oaks ranch comm link on
yourself you can order yours on the link
on the website yeah front page so you
can support a young or your kid 12 years
old business owner so legit way
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
that's also about getting stronger
smarter faster healthier and better the
audio version of that is not on audible
it's on iTunes Amazon music Google Play
it's an album with tracks by the wacky
sure actually it's two albums with
tracks on top of that we got extreme
ownership the book
written by myself and my brother Lafe
babban
it's about combat leadership that's what
it's about and if you want to learn how
to lead you can check out that book also
if your business team or your
organization needs a little extra help
you can utilize our leadership
consulting company called esalaam front
you hear a lot of talk tonight about the
rear echelon that's why we named
national on for national on front the
rear echelon of the people in the rear
national on the front edge salon is the
people in the front lines that's why we
named the organization national on front
because there's a lot of people that
talk about leadership but they're
talking about it from the rear echelon
from the back we're talking about it
from the front our experiences on the
front lines we solve problems whatever
problems through leadership so that's
our company national on fronts me Lafe
Babb and JP Danelle Dave Burke you can
email info a national on front comm or
the website you can check it out if you
want to and finally if you haven't heard
yet the muster Washington DC May 17th
and 18th San Francisco October 17th and
18th we've had four of them in the past
two years actually like the last year
and a half they all sold out this one's
gonna sell out too it is a Leadership
Conference where we drill down on how to
lead give leadership tools tactics
strategies that will allow you to lead
and win a salon front that's our event
you can register for it extreme
ownership calm and if you want to
continue talking with us or you have
questions or if you have answers if you
want to tell me a mistake that I made in
the podcast tonight which I'm sure I did
or you have comments you want to make as
to what we do here you can find us on
the interwebs on Twitter on Instagram
and on the fascia poha echo is at
Oh Charles and I am at the jock a
willing and finally thank you for
listening to the show thank you for
supporting the show thank you for
spreading the word thanks to those of
you that make this podcast possible the
men and women of our armed services that
protect our freedom and especially in
this case our right to free speech to
the police firefighters paramedics and
other first responders that are out
there every day keeping us safe of thank
you and everyone else that is listening
thank you for standing up and leading
yourself leaving yourself away from
weakness and toward strength away from
laziness and toward action away from
comfort and towards the discipline away
from catastrophe and toward victory keep
leading and keep getting after it and
until next time this is echo and Jocko
out